ASMR Video
Ich war heute wieder verstört Leute
auf Twitch
Ich hab Twitch aufgemacht
und da wurde mir auf der linken Seite
ein
Poolstream empfohlen
Da dachte ich mir so, weißt du was
Klickst du da mal drauf
Klicke ich drauf
Gab es eine Webcam
Auf den Arsch
Eine Webcam
Für die Boobs
Und eine Webcam für den Rest
Und was mich am allermeisten verstört hat ist
Ja genau die war das
Ja die war das auch
Und was mich am allermeisten
verstört hat ist
In der Mitte des Bildschirms
Wie viel Zuschauer
4000 oder so
In der Mitte des Bildschirms lief random
Einfach ein Valorant Video
Und ich hab mich so einfach
Jetzt, ich hab es nicht verstanden
Warum läuft da ein Valorant Video
Das hat nichts, wirklich gar nichts
Mit dem Rest zu tun
Ist das, dass man Gaming dran schreiben kann
Und das nicht gegen TOS ist
Oder was, was war, verstehe ich nicht
Wilder Igel, danke für den Sub
Also
Das muss irgendwas mit Twitch
Regeln zu tun haben
Anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären
Weil das hat nichts
Mit dem Content zu tun gehabt, gar nichts
Dann guck es dir an
Ich mach das jetzt hier nicht auf
Ja, ich hab es nicht verstanden
Ich bin ziemlich im Arsch
Kaputtge
Ziemlich
Ziemlich kaputt
Ich bin heute Morgen
1 Stunde 40 oder so
Gelaufen, also nicht gerannt
Wirklich nur normal gelaufen
Und ich bin noch
2 Stunden 30 heute Fahrrad gefahren
Heute Mittag
Ich hab sogar auf Twitter
Ein paar Bilder gepostet
Cubecon
Warst du auf der Cubecon
Oder hast du einfach nur viel Cubecon geguckt
Guck mal, sieht nett aus, oder
Chatgame
Den nehm ich auch
Kann man das irgendwie ordentlich groß machen
Sieht nett aus, oder
Also das ist auf
Du warst vor Ort
MrSNLive
Dankeschön für den Sub
Ja, das ist bei uns so der höchste
Der höchste Berg in der Nähe
Wo ich drauf
Wobei, der höchste Berg in der Nähe ist das hier
Ja, das ist der höchste Berg in der Nähe
Da wo der Turm drauf steht
Hier ist ein bisschen tiefer
Nicht wirklich so viel tiefer
SebiDev, danke für den Sub
Also hier dürften so
Hier dürften nochmal so 30, 40 Meter tiefer sein
Als zum Turm
Das ist nicht der Taunus
Das ist Anfang vom Spessart
Das ist der Hahnenkamm bei Alzenau
Hier hinten
Und das ist
Was ihr hier seht
Das ist übrigens alles
Von der Tür
Von dem Dorf
Das ist das Dorf
Kleinhemmsbach
Hört sich genauso groß an
Wie es ist
Das ist alles
Mehr ist da nicht
Also hier kommt auch nichts mehr
Aber, oh, oh, Chemtrails
Soweit das Auge reicht, Leute
Richtig, richtig nice
Ist das etwa Leak?
Ja, ganz schrecklicher Leak ist das
Guck mal hier hinten
Was ist das?
Hier hinten sieht man
Sind das Windkraftreifen?
Räder?
Windkraftanlagen?
Hier hinten in der Entfernung
Sieht ein bisschen so aus, gell?
Also hier bin ich einmal schon raufgefahren
Zu dem Turm
Da musste nochmal ordentlich steil rauf
Da hatte ich heute keinen Bock
Ich bin lieber die andere Seite raufgefahren
Und bin dann da hinten runtergefahren
Zumindest
Ich sage euch Leute
Es war echt anstrengend hier raufzukommen
Das waren
Weiß nicht so 4, 5
Na eher 5, 6 würde ich sagen
5, 6 Kilometer
Und
Das ging zwischenzeitlich 14% steil hoch
Ich sage euch
Das ist nicht ohne gewesen
Ich bin da jetzt nicht schnell hochgefahren
Aber
Da hat selbst im allerleichtesten Gang
War das doch immer noch anstrengend
Also das war echt super
Es war nice
Es war nice die Runde
Aber es war auch echt anstrengend
Ich fahre das demnächst an mit der GoPro
Da kann ich irgendwie mal
Wenn ich ein Video wieder aufnehmen sollte
Mal 10 Minuten in den Hintergrund packen
Für zur Entspannung
Weil was ich
Wenn ich über irgendwas labere
Und dazu ein paar Sachen einblende
Ist eigentlich fast zweitrangig
Was wirklich im Hintergrund läuft
So in der Zwischenzeit
Sibidev Borg Subscription
Hatten wir doch erst
Das ist noch gar nicht so lange her
Dass ich Plants vs. Zombie habe
Übrigens eine Sache habe ich gemerkt
Wenn ich so lange unterwegs draußen war
Da merke ich das im Hals
Wahrscheinlich weil man so viel kalte Luft
Gegen den Hals gekriegt hat
Die ganze Zeit
Also Fahrtwind
Nicht das ich wüsste
Ne
Zumal du mit den klassischen Fahrradträgern
Ehe aufpassen musst
Mit Carbonfahrrädern
Die darfst du nicht so
Darfst du nicht so
Nicht so fest einklemmen
Am Rahmen
Je nachdem was du da für einen hast
Also wie gesagt
Aber nicht das ich wüsste
Ich glaube nicht
Das man da dann
Gepäckträger drauf machen kann
Also Fahrradträger
Brauch ich auch nicht
Ich kann ja von daheim aus fahren
Wir haben ja bei uns genug
Genug Sachen in der Nähe
Das einzig dumme ist
Das ich
Gerade den Stückchen vom Hinweg
Und den Rückweg
Sehr viel durch den Wald fahren musste
Und der ist natürlich
Noch nass gewesen
Vom Regen
Der letzten Tage
Ich hatte
So schön mein Fahrrad geputzt
Am Wochenende
Freitag Samstag
So
Weiß nicht mal welcher Tag
Ist auch wurscht
Yaks
Genau
Will mich mit Yaks einloggen
Und jetzt ist es wieder
Dreckiges
Fuck
Aber eins muss ich sagen
Die gewachste Kette
Fühlt sich nice an
Es fühlt sich alles sehr
Ruhig
Geschmeidig
An
Und
Das ist
Die
Ruhig
Geschmeidig
Und
Locker an
Ich hab ein Video gesehen
Dass man die nochmal
Nachwachsen soll
Nachdem man gefahren ist
Und alles getrocknet ist
Beim ersten Mal
Werde ich dann morgen machen
Und das nächste Mal
Hol ich mir Heißwachs
Dann wird die Fahrradkette
Heiß gewachst
Bam
Dann
Optimum
Ich habe das Fahrrad
Gemoddet
Ein bisschen
Ich mach mal Update
Während ich erzähle
Und dann gucken wir uns an
Was
Heute
Ansteht
Ich hab mir mein Fahrrad
Minimal
Gemoddet
Ich hab ne größere Kassette
Drauf gemacht
Die
Leicht
Außerhalb
Der
Spezifikation
Ist
Was
Für
Die
Schaltung
Zugelassen
Ist
Wieder
Alles
Repariert
Du
Meinst
An
Hast
Jetzt
Ostern
Nee
Ich hab
Am
Nächste Woche
Donnerstag
Eintagurlaub
Da hab ich Donnerstag
Freitag Samstag Sonntag
Montag frei
Wobei Montag hätte ich auch so
Freu
Ich lad mir schon mal
Debian
Aktuelles runter
We are sorry
Ja
Firefox
Zurecht
Später
Eigentlich bin ich echt
Pepega
Warum
Lade ich mir nicht einfach
Netboot runter
Installier einfach alles
Über Netboot
Ah
Wurscht
Warum
Nicht
Vor
Am
Jam
Weil
Wir
Nested
Virtualisierung
Machen
Müssen
Nämlich
Verarschen
Muss
Ich
Sagen
Current
Ist
Jetzt
Auch
Book
Warum
Ist
Das
So
Super
Kompliziert
Sich
Debian
Iso
Neuerdings
Runterzuladen
Wisst
Ihr
Was
Ich
Mach
Einfach
Lose
Normalerweise
Klickst
Hier
Isos
Mehr
Runter
Ich
Benutze
Netboot
Das
Ist
Einfach
So
Viel
Angenehmer
Ja
Netboot
Wo
Ist
Es
Denn
Iso
Netboot
X
Y
Z
Iso
Pass
Auf
Das
Ist
Was
Aber
Das
Ist
Aber
Das
Ist
Nicht
Das
Ist
wie platz habe ich noch auf c ich möchte es ja danach wieder haben wir als genug so
single file 200 gig nicht dass wir die hier brauchen würden next next printer weg sound
karte weg usb ich nicht so und da machen wir jetzt netboot hin nein nicht windows netboot
klaus zeige ich was das coole netboot ist man muss ja ja das ist richtig man muss theoretisch
noch nicht mal das isolaten man kann auch in seinen pxe server das schmeißen und jetzt pass
mal auf wenn ich das jetzt starte dann startet netboot xyz und über netboot also ich habe auch
ich habe auch ein usb stick am start mit vento drauf mit ein paar isos und netboot und über
netboot kann ich auch mit netboot mit netboot starten und ich kann auch mit netboot starten
einfach alles weitere nach installieren was ich brauche dass hier linux wollen wir installieren
debian network installs debian bookworm x-base install let's go fertig für was xyz das ist die
domain warum die xyz als domain haben keine ahnung ist etwas mega nice wäre wenn vmware
workstation diese iso sachen irgendwie in den in den create vm integrieren würde vielleicht sogar
noch mit cloud initiaten
support dann wird sie nämlich wirklich nur zweimal weiter klicken und sagen debian
image dann wird dann cloud image runterladen customizen starten das wäre eine sache von
keine ahnung 30 sekunden da werde ich vor allem am start max hast du mitbekommen dass es jetzt
knu kobold gibt das gibt es doch schon die ganze zeit das ist doch nichts neues wir sind wir sind
in europe wir sind in germany united states kona alles klar key map german
ich hinterlebe an dem ja das brauche als als base für heute so und wären das ist ja die jetzt zeige
ich euch was ich mir mal angucken wollte nämlich erstmal warten bis der hier netzwerk network
config hat warum ist der hostname standardmäßig shit warum ist der haus neben standardmäßig schritt
ich glaube weil diese ip schon mal benutzt war und beim dhcp das irgendwie ist aber es wird auch so
gut weil ich glaube ich habe hier jetzt auch noch ein paar einzige ip modernen bundeswege noch ein
bisschen mehr grüßen und das ich habe meine homepage hier auf der pushing71 und das ist忧
noch irgendwie drin hatte, oder?
Ich hab das noch nie gesehen,
dass der Standard,
dass das Standard Debian
irgendwie als Hostname shit hat.
Yep, Cockpit
ist das. Ja, okay.
Aber auch allein schon,
weil der die Domain vom,
der hat garantiert die Domain und sowas
über DHCP bekommen.
Und wahrscheinlich
hat die
MAC-Adresse schon mal irgendwas
gehabt.
Kann das sein, dass zufälligerweise die
MAC-Adresse schon mal in Benutzung
war und das ein
Server war, der shit hieß?
Hot Cheesecake.
Ja. Dankeschön für den
Sub. Nein, die Chance ist nicht
2 hoch
48, weil die
MAC-Adressen nicht komplett
randomized werden bei
VMware. Und ich hab
Bridge Networking, das stimmt. Ja, du hast recht.
Aber Bridge Networking nimmt noch
mal eine andere... Aber das kann
sein, dass Bridge Networking
auch nicht komplett random ist.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall nicht komplett random.
Die ersten Stellen sind immer gleich, weil VMware...
Ja.
Im Endeffekt, es kommt garantiert vom
DHCP. Wie soll das vom
DNS kommen? So.
Passwort. Root User. Leute,
Best Practice.
Da kommt keiner drauf. Ich meine,
es geht doch immer
darum, dass das, was viele Leute
benutzen, gut ist. Und ich glaube,
das ist das meistbenutzte Passwort der Welt.
Das kann also nicht schlecht sein. Sonst würden das
nicht so viele Leute benutzen.
Neuer User. Ja, okay. Den brauchen wir aber gar
nicht. Aber der kriegt auch 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6.
Das Passwort ist
Industriestandard. Ja.
Entire Disk.
Yes.
Yes. Ich mag die Debian-Installation.
Diese Encurses-basierte
Installation. Die ist so simpel.
Du kannst im Prinzip immer weiter, weiter.
Next, next, next. So. Also,
jetzt zeige ich euch,
was ich eigentlich mir angucken möchte.
Und zwar möchte ich mir Cockpit
Project angucken.
Das ist ein Webinterface
für Linux. Ich glaube, ursprünglich wurde
das Ganze mal von Red Hat entwickelt.
Und da kannst du jede Menge
verschiedene Sachen drüber machen.
Ja, man sieht das auch, weil er standardmäßig Fedora.
Ich meine, wer verwendet der noch irgendwie noch
ganz bei Sinnen ist?
Fedora.
Aber da siehst du,
dass das irgendwie mal aus der Richtung
Red Hat kommt. Ja.
Da kannst du deinen Linux-Server damit verwalten
über das Webinterface. Und normalerweise,
ihr kennt mich, schwöre ich
auf SSH und
CLI-Administration.
Mache ich auch weiterhin. Aber
so ein paar Module, das ist
wie Webmin, nur nicht scheiße.
Nur der Unterschied ist,
im Heimbereich,
also privat, enjoye ich
schon ein gutes Webinterface.
Allerdings nicht
für diesen ganzen Kram, also Networking,
würde ich da drüber nicht machen.
Irgendein Raid-Setup würde ich da drüber nicht machen.
Das mache ich alles schön per SSH von Hand.
Ja, und Disk-Encryption und sonst was.
Terminal brauche ich auch nicht drüber.
Aber, wofür
ich mir vorstelle, ist es ganz gut.
Also, wofür ich mir
vorstellen könnte, dass es ganz gut ist, ist
zum Beispiel für VMs.
Also, der Hintergrund ist
folgender. Ich habe ja bei mir daheim
seit einer ganzen Weile eine
Unraid-Kiste. Warum
Unraid? Ja, weil es irgendwie so das
kleinste Übel war.
Ich bin nicht wirklich glücklich damit.
Es hat schon so ein paar Sachen, die
mir nicht gefallen. Zum Beispiel ist
das Webinterface ein bisschen
ja, weiß nicht, ein bisschen
langweilig
so. Und, ja, langweilig ist das falsche Wort.
Ein bisschen sehr
rudimentär an manchen Stellen noch.
Und auch VMs anlegen
darüber ist nicht so schön.
Auch die Patch-Geschwindigkeit
ist teilweise sehr lahm. Die brauchen
teilweise Wochen, Monate,
bis irgendwas gepatcht ist.
Auf der anderen Seite
ist mein Hauptanwendungszweck
auch nicht nur Virtualisierung
bei mir daheim. Im Heimbereich
habe ich drei Sachen, die ich brauche.
Ich brauche
ein paar
Windows-Shares im Netzwerk.
Ich brauche
ein paar VMs.
Und ich brauche
einige Docker-Container.
Fertig. So.
Kein Bock, bei mir privat einen Kubernetes
laufen zu lassen, so wie das...
Wie heißt der Typ nochmal mit dem Kubernetes-Cluster
daheim? Techno-Tim
oder so, gell?
Techno-Tim heißt er so?
Ja, der Dude. Der...
Oh, Moment! Es gibt ein
Homelab-Update. Das muss ich mir angucken.
Eine neue
Homelab-Tour. Na.
Drei Kubernetes-Cluster, würde ich
sagen, hat er jetzt noch zusätzlich bekommen daheim.
After giving you a tour... Also, der hat
ja auch irgendwie zig Kubernetes... Ich weiß nicht,
was mit den Leuten los ist. Also, ich
werde mir definitiv kein Kubernetes-Cluster daheim
hinstellen. Da muss ich mich
auf der Arbeit schon drum kümmern und
für verteilte,
skalierbare Workloads alles wunderbar.
Nice, aber nicht daheim.
So. Und
wenn es im Datacenter ist, dann ist es
kein Homelab mehr.
Ja.
Der hat auch ein Kubernetes.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum man daheim Kubernetes
betreibt.
Ich... Ich verstehe.
Ich verstehe den Reiz
dahinter, weil das eine sehr nice
Technologie ist und es auch
enorm viel für den Job
bringt, sich damit im Detail
auseinanderzusetzen.
Ja genau, dafür ist das gut.
Aber wenn man will, dass das einfach nur
daheim möglichst gut
funktioniert und ohne
größeren Aufwand,
da ist so ein Kubernetes-Cluster
jetzt vielleicht
nicht die allerbeste
Idee. Wenn man will,
dass es einfach nur funktioniert,
ganz ehrlich,
dann würde ich sagen, ist wahrscheinlich,
wenn man das Geld für hat, irgendein
Synology NAS, noch das mit Abstand
einfachste. Da hast du alles
auf einen Schlag,
VMware-Verwaltung, Docker und
alles mögliche, was man
halt so braucht. Auf der anderen
Seite
ist mir ein Synology NAS
dann auch schon wieder zu sehr von
der Stange. Schwer zu beschreiben.
DarkSide, danke schön für den
Sub. Deswegen, bisher hatte ich
bei mir daheim immer, also ich hatte lange Zeit
bei mir daheim einfach nur einen
Linux-Server,
Ubuntu, dann
Debian, dann wieder Ubuntu,
dann wieder, also irgendwas
Debian-basiertes, Hot-Cheesecake,
danke schön für den Sub.
SebiDev, Pog, auch am Start, ah ne, euch habe ich schon
gesehen. Und irgendwann
habe ich mir gedacht, also so der Weisheitsletzter
Schluss ist es ja nicht.
Und dann habe ich mir mal ein Unraid installiert.
Unraid ist für mich ein ganz guter Kompromiss aus
man kann ganz sinnvoll Docker-Container
mit verwalten, man kann relativ
gut VMs damit anlegen und man kann
Netzwerk sharen und
ihr Raid-System
finde ich tatsächlich auch ganz nice
bei Unraid,
weil du kannst
einfach alle möglichen Laufwerke
zusammenstöpseln und das macht nicht wirklich
echtes Raid, wie man das so kennt
auf quasi
Weis-Ebene, sondern das macht
so ein asynchrones Raid
mit
erst geht es auf den Cache, dann geht es auf
die Disk und oben drüber ist
das eigentlich bloß so ein großes
Union-File-System, was aber auch den Vorteil
hat, dass wenn eine
Festplatte kaputt geht, dass
dann, du kannst also
recoveren die Festplatte, du kannst aber
auch die Festplatte abmachen und woanders anschließen
und da hast du halt genau die Daten drauf, die halt gerade drauf
liegen. Das ist, das ist eigentlich ganz gut gemacht.
Aber so wirklich glücklich bin
ich damit nicht, deswegen habe ich mir überlegt,
ich gucke mir mal ein paar Alternativen an.
Proxmox ist auch für mich daheim
nicht so das Wahre.
Ich bin weg, also ich habe auch mal ZFS gemacht
bei mir daheim, finde ich da jetzt auch nicht
so optimal für und
Proxmox
hat halt keine Möglichkeit von Plugins
und ist halt hauptsächlich
auf Virtualisierung
spezialisiert.
Wow, was macht meine Uhr denn jetzt?
Ah, ich habe
Messages bekommen und
ne, ich habe es einfach vorher nicht gesehen,
ich habe gerade bei mir reingeguckt.
Unraid macht tatsächlich,
ja, ja, Unraid macht Parity Checks.
Da musst du, das musst du aber manuell.
So, ZFS
bin ich weg von mir daheim, ich brauche
die meisten ZFS, ZFS ist nice.
Ich habe auf der Arbeit letztens erst was mit
ZFS gebaut, aber für mir daheim
ist das nichts. Und
Proxmox ist cool, aber
Proxmox ist zu
virtualisierungsfokussiert.
Ja, keine Raid-Geschichten und
keine Share-Konfigurationen über
das Webinterface und auch das
Containerhandling ist nur so
so semi. Wobei
man sagen muss, man kann das ganz gut machen, man
kann sich ja sein Docker mit
Docke oder sowas, wenn man ein Webinterface haben will,
dort einfach rein
eliminieren, wie man das früher genannt hat.
In irgendeine VM
oder in irgendeinen LXC-Container und dann geht
das auch. Ja, aber ein schönes
Webinterface, finde ich, hat Proxmox auch nicht.
Ich finde, es gibt für den Heimbereich
keine schöne
universal
Linux-Lösung.
Die Leute, die keinen Bock haben, sich
damit zu beschäftigen, die können sich ein Synology NAS
kaufen und sind glücklich damit.
Nein, TrueNAS hat mir
überhaupt nicht gefallen.
TrueNAS hat als Containerverwaltung
ein Kubernetes mit
Helm-Chart-Webinterface. Das fand
ich ganz weird. Das mag
sein. Ich persönlich habe
allerdings nur Verwendung für sowas wie Proxmox
und vor allem, wer eher im Enterprise umfällt.
Und da wird es wahrscheinlich
so gut wie immer vor allem, wobei man weiß,
das in Zukunft nicht, wie das mit
Prodcom und den Lizenzen weitergeht.
Aber allein schon im Enterprise-Umfeld
ist VMware einfach so etabliert,
die haben ihre eigene
Zertifizierungskram,
total viele Leute, die sich damit
auskennen. Das ist auch schon
sehr etabliert. Die meisten Unternehmen haben schon
VMware-Klasse. Die werden das nicht durch Proxmox
ablösen.
Also, deswegen bin ich
bisher auf... Was mir auch an Unraid nicht
gefällt, noch eine weitere Sache, die mir an Unraid
nicht gefällt, ist, dass es auf Slackware basiert.
Also, da kannst du gar nicht so sehr
was customizen, wenn du nicht die Software irgendwie
dir selbst kompilieren möchtest
für Slackware. Open Media Vault
gefällt mir auch nicht.
Das habe ich auch schon ausprobiert.
Ich habe mehr oder weniger alles durch.
Und ehrlich, für
meinen Einsatzzweck muss
ich sagen, ist Unraid immer
noch so bisher das
Beste von den
schlechten Systemen im Heimbereich.
Nee, das ist nicht der FreeNAS
Typ der Open Media Vault.
TrueNAS ist der Nachfolger von FreeNAS.
Also, was
meiner Meinung nach Unraid wirklich noch
gut tun würde, ist, wenn
wenn die mal ein bisschen mehr
Designarbeit
in ihre
VM-Erstellungs
Webinterface
werfen würden.
Also, wenn man sich das beispielsweise
Barbara Hetzner anguckt, wie easy man da mit
drei Klicks eine VM starten
kann. Warum muss das
so kompliziert sein? Weil es ist nicht wirklich
kompliziert. Ja, aber allein schon,
dass es kein Cloud Image Support gibt
in Unraid für eine VM ist doof.
Dass es keine automatische Image
Auswahl gibt ist doof.
Also mit einem Dropdown, da musst du immer dann
ISO auswählen.
Und dass man kein Cloud Image Support hat
ist auch doof.
Muss man nicht mittlerweile für
Unraid zahlen? Ja.
Ab 27.
Also du musst schon immer für Unraid zahlen.
Aber ab 27. ist es ein Abo
Modell, Unraid. Auch wenn Unraid
sagt, dass es kein Abo Modell ist.
Aber es ist ein Abo Modell. Weil man kauft
sich's und dann muss man jährlich neu bezahlen, um
Updates zu bekommen. Also ja, es ist ein Abo Modell.
Ja, ganz ehrlich,
wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich wäre
das Beste immer noch
einfach
ein ganz normaler Debian Server daheim hinzustellen.
Und gut
ist. Aber ich muss
ehrlich sagen, der Einfachheit halber
so im privaten, im Heimbereich
ich enjoye halt echt so ein gutes
Web Interface.
Find das nice.
Doge finde ich auch nice, was ich
gesehen habe. Wie gesagt, rein für den Heimbereich.
Quasi so ein
Web UI für Docker Compose
Files. Eigentlich eine ziemlich coole Idee.
Super simpel, aber eine gute Idee.
Wenn es noch den VM Champ mit
Web Interface gäbe, dann wäre ich happy.
Ja, Unraid.
Guck mal, Unraid Pricing. Passt mal auf.
Das sind die aktuellen Lizenzen.
Also im Prinzip aktuell, beziehungsweise
bezahlt man 60 Euro Lifetime.
Und jetzt
ab 27.
kostet es
49 Euro. Dafür
jährliche
Servicegebühr
von 36 Euro.
Und wisst ihr, was ich besonders witzig finde, ist
dass das offensichtlich
ein Abo
Modell ist.
49 Euro kaufen und dann jährlich
36 Euro fortsetzen.
Das ist offensichtlich ein Abo Modell.
Ach ja, die Lifetime Unlimited Lizenz
ist damit quasi doppelt so teuer wie vorher.
Es ist offensichtlich ein Abo Modell.
Aber in der FAQ
schreiben sie
Is Unraid OS a Subscription?
No.
Nein, nein.
Jährlich verlängern ist
definitiv kein Abo Modell.
No.
Also Leute, wir haben uns leider täuschen lassen.
Es ist doch kein Abo Modell.
Wir bezahlen jährlich, aber es ist kein Abo Modell.
Okay?
Ihr seid geil, alle.
Oh Mann.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht,
lange Rede, kurzer Sinn jetzt.
wir gucken uns einfach mal Cockpit an,
wie Cockpit so ist.
Und was man damit so machen kann.
Schadet doch nichts.
Oh, ich hätte mal,
ich hätte mal in dem Jahr weiterklicken müssen.
Kein Desktop Environments, Alter.
Standard Utilities und SSH Server.
Jawoll.
Naja, also,
dass sie den USB Stick
pro Lizenz wollen,
das kann ich schon irgendwie verstehen.
Die wollen halt,
dass du nicht irgendwie,
dass du dir ein Abo kaufst,
keine Lizenz kaufst,
die dann auf 10 Systemen parallel
benutzt.
Das verstehe ich schon.
Dass sie das mit der Hardware ID
vom USB Stick gemacht haben.
Ich habe, wie gesagt,
kein Problem damit gehabt.
Auf ein jährliches Update habe ich keinen Bock.
Was aber auch nicht schlimm ist,
weil die alten Lizenzen bleiben ja erhalten.
Ja, also, das muss man auch nochmal sagen.
Man wird nicht zwangsumgestellt auf Abo-Modell.
Man kann, wenn man will,
aber man kann auch seine alte Lifetime Lizenz behalten.
Was Android macht,
ja, es ist,
für mich ist es halt ein Abo.
Ich habe heute ein bisschen in der GoPro App rumgeklickt
und das erste, was die mir verkaufen wollten,
war ein Premium-Abo.
49 Euro im Jahr.
Überall, wir hatten es letztens,
ich habe mich erst letztens darüber ausgekotzt,
überall wollen sie
irgendwelchen
Krempel als As-a-Service dir
aufs Auge drücken.
Also, wie gesagt, ich finde es nicht schlimm,
dass sie das bisher gemacht haben.
Und dass Android von einem USB Stick läuft,
ist ja auch nicht schlimm,
weil das System ist im Rahmen.
Der USB Stick wird ja nicht benutzt,
und man kann den sogar backuppen,
wenn man möchte,
auf einen anderen USB Stick.
Also, das ist schon okay.
Ja,
ja, ja, ja, ja.
Doch, doch, doch, also angeblich schon.
Angeblich bleibt die
alte Lifetime Lizenz bestehen
und man bekommt auch weiterhin Updates.
So habe ich das zumindest verstanden.
Die gehen mir alle so auf den Sack.
Übrigens von meinen China-Chinesen
Steckdosenleisten
ist mir ernsthaft
innerhalb von eineinhalb Wochen
drei Stück verreckt jetzt.
Und ich glaube, das liegt nicht an mir,
sondern einfach an,
die sind ungefähr gleich alt.
Die Dinger sind einfach schlechte Qualität.
Oh.
Ich muss erstmal wieder runterfahren.
Power off.
Ach Moment, wir sind unter Debian,
da geht's so nur nicht.
Power off.
Ich muss ja erstmal GPU pa...
Manchmal gehe ich
zu schnell, bevor ich denke.
Nein, nicht GPU passthrough.
Nein, das muss ich nicht machen.
Ich muss Nested-Virtualisierung
einschalten, das wollte ich sagen.
GPU passthrough mit Forever Workstation
wäre mega, wenn das gehen würde.
Ohne Scheiß, das wäre so geil.
Aber das geht nicht.
Mal ein Bastelstream und wir suchen
den Fehler. Von was?
Welche IP haben wir denn?
2.30
SSH
Achso.
Hatten wir auch schon mal an.
Wie ging das nochmal?
SSH Higen minus R
Yes.
Yep, Cockpit.
Alter, wir sind Debian.
Steckdosen, achso.
Ehrlich gesagt
will ich das nicht machen.
Weil das die Leute dazu
verleitet Steckdosenleisten aufzuschrauben,
daran rumzubasteln und danach wieder an Strom
zu stecken.
Ne, ich schmeiß die Dinger weg.
Glücklicherweise
kann ich die Dinger mittlerweile ohne Probleme
wegschmeißen, weil
alle meine WLAN-Geräte
ein eigenes Passwort haben fürs
WLAN. Das heißt, ich schmeiß jetzt
die WLAN-Steckdose in Müll,
dann liegt quasi dort in meiner
Mülltonne das WLAN-Passwort
auf einem Flash-Chip,
aber das ist nicht mehr
gültig, weil jedes Gerät ein eigenes
WLAN-Passwort hat. Also,
ich glaube,
dass irgendwas
da drinnen kaputt ist,
dass 230 Volt
auf die 3,3 Volt-Leitung
gekommen sind. Weil
die LEDs
haben so im 50 Hertz
Rhythmus geblinkt.
So ganz komisch, so ganz
schnell 50 Hertz ungefähr.
Was eigentlich nicht sein kann,
weil dann würden die instant durchbrennen,
aber
irgendwie ergibt das für mich keinen Sinn.
Also, ich glaube, da ist was grundlegend
drinnen kaputt.
Wenn der Stromausfall schuld war?
Ne, ähm,
eine ist vor dem Stromausfall kaputt gegangen,
eine ist beim Stromausfall kaputt gegangen
und eine andere ist irgendwie einen Tag nach
dem Stromausfall kaputt gegangen. Also,
der Stromausfall war es nicht.
Restmüll ist nicht immer optimal, da hast du recht, ja.
Aber vielleicht bin ich einfach
zu faul. So.
Ja, hier haben wir unsere Debian-Kiste.
Wir machen mal kurz für ein Update.
Wie?
Achso, ja, gut, ich habe das aktuellste
Netinstall-ISO. Wäre ja
auch sehr merkwürdig, ne?
Wenn nicht. Also, wir haben
Upinstall-Temux, erstmal so ein paar Basics,
Hardtop und Vim.
Werden wir auf jeden Fall brauchen
auf der Debian-Kiste.
Gut, dann gucken wir uns doch mal an. Wie installiert
man Cockpit? Ich würde versuchen
sie nochmal zu flashen, eventuell ist der ROM kaputt.
Ne, das Ding geht
gar nicht mehr an. Ja, ja, das könnte
man alles machen, aber ich will, ehrlich gesagt,
das gar nicht fixen.
Das Ding ist kaputt
und wenn es
einmal kaputt geht, habe ich,
traue ich dem nicht. Das fliegt
in die Tonne. Ich bin auch,
ich bin auf der Suche. Kennt jemand eine gute
Meta- oder
Zigbee-Thread, was auch immer.
Steckdosenleiste?
Ikea
hatte, glaube ich, mal welche. Unter Lidl.
Zigbee, Zigbee-Steckdosenleisten.
Da kann man
schnell nebenbei gucken bei Amazon.
Meta-Steck...
Ja, Schrott,
man.
Ich will schon irgendwas haben,
was nicht China-Chinesen-App braucht.
Zigbee.
Ich meine, das sieht doch eigentlich ganz sympathisch
aus, hier sowas in der Richtung.
Bisschen mehr USB-Anschlüsse dürfte
die haben. Zau, zau.
Ja, also
solange ich, solange ich keine China-
Tuya-Hub, ne, bloß nicht.
Solange ich keine China-Chinesen-Steckdosen-
App brauche, ist alles gut.
Lidl, Zigbee,
Steckdosenleiste.
Welche, welche habt ihr da? Das da,
gell? Die,
ja, okay, die hat immerhin,
immerhin hat die vier USB-
Stecker. Also wisst ihr, wisst ihr,
was meine perfekte Steckdosenleiste wär?
Wer kennt die Weltmarke Zau, Zau
nicht? Ja, cringe, wer das nicht kennt.
Wisst ihr, was meine Lieblings-
Steckdosenleiste wär? Vier Stecker.
Vier USB,
äh, Stecker.
Und davon mindestens einer mit
Quick Charge.
Das wäre sehr, sehr nice.
Okay, also,
wie installiert man Cockpit?
Yep, Cockpit.
Debian.
View Instructions. Okay, was muss man
machen? Wir muss, äh,
ETCUS Release
sourcen. Okay.
Why not?
Dann muss man random Sachen
in seine
Apt-Sources eintragen.
Okay, dann macht man Apt-Apt.
Ja, schön, aber schön, dass sie in Repo
zur Verfügung stellen. Das finde ich doch schon mal ganz nice.
Und dann
sagt man
Apt-Install minus T
Backport
Was, was macht denn,
was macht denn Apt-Install
minus T?
Das verwendet man nie.
Minus T. Das Repo?
Minus T.
Ach,
Target Release.
Okay, das ist ja sehr weird,
dass man das überhaupt braucht.
Bumm.
Wow, wow, okay.
Was, was, was enthält der alles?
Cockpit Bridge, Cockpit
Package.
Installiert der auch
LibVirt und solche
Geschichten?
BTFS Tools?
Viel Kram dabei.
Aber gut, wir haben auch ein
minimal Net Install
Debian, da ist nicht viel drauf.
Ja, Webmin ist aber richtig
Schrott gewesen. Ich glaube das hier ist ganz brauchbar.
Ich mein,
wenn man das wirklich ernsthaft betreiben will
und auch nicht daheim, sondern wirklich nur remote,
dann führt kein Weg
an reinem
SSH-Administrieren vorbei.
Aber da willst du ja dann auch
keine Summershares für lokale
Sachen anlegen oder ein paar VMs
aufstarten.
Muss LibVirt Plugin für Cockpit noch installieren.
Ja, sehen wir dann. Gucken wir uns an.
Ich hab, keine Ahnung, ich hab mir das vor Jahren mal kurz angeguckt.
Da war ich nicht so begeistert von.
So wie, ich weiß nicht,
irgendjemand hat fast das gleiche vorhin im Chat geschrieben.
Kriegen wir auch so.
Und jetzt einfach mal schauen, wie sich das Ganze so entwickelt hat.
So, Netstat, wo läuft das Ganze?
Kein Netstat drauf.
Das ist aber wirklich schon...
Gibt es Netstat überall als eigenes Paket?
Oder braucht man da IP,
IP-Utils oder irgendwie sowas? Ach,
ich kann...
Netstat, was muss man installieren unter
Debian? IP-Utils
oder irgendwie sowas?
Äh, Netstat-Beste.
Net, Net-Tools.
Net-Tools.
Debian mit ihren Google-Package-Namen.
Man hätte aber auch
suchen können.
Tulben-Beste.
Okay, äh.
Ich sehe hier kein Cockpit.
Hat das mit dem Installieren, hat das oben funktioniert?
Ja.
Wurde das nicht gestartet
oder so?
Ich sehe hier nichts.
Was, Port 9090? Wo?
Nee.
Moment, Moment.
Init? Steht da was von 9090?
Ach ja.
Ach nee,
man muss erst mal starten, okay.
Ach, man kann die ZigBee-Leiste flashen?
Ah, cool.
Was läuft denn da drauf?
Ha, ach so.
Okay.
Das muss man aufmachen und muss ein ESP reinschrauben.
Reinschrauben.
Ja, okay.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das ist eine ZigBee-Leiste.
ZigBee ist auch okay, da brauche ich kein Dasmotor.
Okay, whatever.
Es sollte ja schon laufen.
Okay, probieren wir das mal aus.
Auf Porters 9090.
Oh.
Achtung.
Super gefährlich.
Server, yep, Cockpit.
Okay.
Cockpit, Default, Passwort.
Oder ist es das System?
Okay, also kann ich jetzt quasi sagen,
Max, 123456.
Ah, okay,
das Benutzsystem, Authentifizierung.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Web Console is running in limited access.
Natürlich.
Passwort für...
Ach, okay, es ist kein sudo installiert.
Kann man sich...
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Kann man sich als Root einloggen?
Das hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert,
wenn das geht, das wäre ja schon ziemlich...
Okay, muss ich...
Seriously, muss ich jetzt sudo draufmachen
dafür?
Wahrscheinlich, ne?
Cockpit, Login, Root.
Vielleicht liegt es aber auch daran,
weil Root SSH
ausgeschaltet ist.
Lass uns das mal ausprobieren.
Ah, Root SSH ist ausgeschaltet, guck mal.
Das könnte es sein.
Aber mit sudo ist es ehrlich gesagt trotzdem schöner.
Wir installieren
immer sudo auf Debian.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher,
was man da alles jetzt konfigurieren muss.
Was?
Hat der installiert?
Ja, aber mein User hat da bestimmt nicht reingepackt, oder?
Ja.
Ähm, ich muss jetzt...
Oh, wie geht das?
UserAds...
Ah, fuck man,
ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
Es ist AddUser, nicht UserAd.
Max in sudo?
Okay.
Oh, gibt es kein sudo?
Moment, gibt es...
Ist da noch gar nichts drinne?
Doch.
Allow members of group sudo to execute any command.
Müsste eigentlich...
Ups, ich noob.
Jetzt habe ich mein Terminal gekillt.
Es kann sein, dass ich mich nochmal neu einloggen muss,
dass das funktioniert.
Ah, yes.
Ne, der Net Install Debian Installer macht das nicht.
Der ist zu minimalistisch.
Ja, UserAd
ist glaube ich das, was so ein Assistent hat.
Was quasi ein Skript ist,
was so ein Assistent, was sich viele Sachen abfragt.
AddUser ist glaube ich das Standard-Command.
Ich kann es mir aber auch immer nicht merken,
welche das Richtige ist.
So, jetzt
loggen wir uns nochmal ein.
AdministrativeAccess, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
Was? Max ist not in the sudo aus file.
Willst du mich verarschen?
Na klar bin ich im sudo aus file.
Ich reboot die jetzt.
Reboot hilft immer.
Kann sein, dass das das noch nicht gecheckt hat.
Ich muss nicht im sudo aus file sein.
Ich kann sudo machen, das muss reichen.
Ich bin in der sudo aus group.
Sudo aus group muss reichen.
So.
Zack.
Max.
Pass mal auf, jetzt wird es funktionieren.
Haha.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Okay.
Warum haben diese Buttons hier oben
so einen hässlichen Rahmen?
Da ist doch schon irgendwas falsch, oder?
Irgendwas ist da kaputt.
Lass mal checken, ob das in Chrome auch so ist.
Naja, it's not private.
Schlimmeres.
Ah, gucke mal.
In Chrome ist es nicht so.
In Firefox ist es broken.
Ach, könnte es an meinem Darkreader liegen?
Das könnte tatsächlich an meinem Darkreader liegen.
So halb, hä?
Es liegt so halb an.
Ne, hier sieht es genau so aus.
Alles gut, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Es liegt echt am Darkreader.
Okay, also.
Was haben wir denn hier schönes?
Wir haben ein Dashboard.
Was macht hier oben dieser Knopf?
Message of the day.
Ja.
Das ist ganz wichtig, dass ich das
auf den ersten Blick hier sehe.
Meine Message of the day.
Weil die sich auch so oft ändert.
Ich finde die gar nicht so hässlich, die Web-UI.
Ich finde sie eigentlich echt ganz, ganz brauchbar.
Okay, man sieht, last successful login.
Systeminformation, alles gut.
Brauchen wir alles net.
Brauchen wir auch alles net.
Metrics and history.
Ganz ehrlich, werde ich mir eh nicht angucken.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Logs kann man sich angucken.
Ja, okay, nice.
Gucke ich mir alles per SSH an. Brauche ich nicht.
Storage.
Partitionen und Auslastung.
Ja, nice to have.
Aber dafür brauche ich kein Web-Interface.
Das mache ich alles über SSH.
Bevor ich in irgendeinem Web-Interface
da rumklickse.
Die Frage ist,
wenn ich jetzt eine weitere
Festplatte dran hätte.
Das probieren wir gerade mal aus.
Könnte ich die
da drüber formatieren?
Nicht, dass ich das je machen würde.
Aber einfach nur
gut zu wissen.
10 Gig.
Moment, falsche VM.
Die VM muss das dran.
Leute, ich habe es auch gecheckt.
Yep, Cockpit 0.
Kannst du?
Aha, er hat es nicht erkannt,
dass es eine neue Platte gibt.
Anscheinend hat der Cockpit
keinen Bock drauf.
Warum hat der
die neue Platte nicht erkannt?
Was ist denn das für ein Schrott?
Ist der Dapper Debian wieder kaputt?
Warum erkennt der die neue
Disk nicht?
Sehr weird.
Reboot.
Das liegt bestimmt an der VM.
Ich gehe fest davon aus,
dass das bei einer echten Kiste erkannt hätte.
Zumindest wenn du USB was
anstöpselst.
Normalerweise erkennt der on the fly,
wenn du neue Festplatten ...
Vielleicht hätte ich ein anderes
Interface auswählen sollen.
Gucken wir mal.
SCB.
Äh, Moment.
Da ist noch gar nichts drauf.
SDA hier.
20 Gig.
Kann man sagen Merke?
Ne.
Also hier hat er es erkannt.
Unformatted Data.
Und was kann man damit jetzt machen?
Create Partition Table.
Unformatted Data.
Ich will keine Partition Table.
Ich will einfach direkt ein File System drauf klatschen.
Round Point.
Type X4.
NTFS.
Exzellent.
Gucken wir mal.
Man kann sogar Encryption machen.
123456.
Bestes Passwort.
Encryption Options.
Default.
Format only.
Dafür braucht man kein Web Interface.
Das macht aus meiner Sicht auch keinen Sinn.
Ich wollte es einfach ausprobieren.
Äh.
Lux und Konsorten sind gar nicht drauf.
Kann das sein?
Oder doch?
Whatever.
Dr. ProNOOBX.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich würde das ehrlich gesagt eh nicht verwenden.
Vielleicht mag Lux das Passwort auch nicht.
Aber da gesagt Crypt Setup nicht gefunden.
Gibt es sowas mittlerweile wie UptSearch?
Früher gab es UptCache und sowas.
Gibt es mittlerweile UptSearch?
Boah.
Alter.
Massive.
Was davon brauche ich jetzt?
Crypt Mount.
Crypt Setup.
Ja.
Also ich probiere das jetzt nochmal.
Ob du das jetzt findest.
Format.
Lux 2.
Massive.
Highly secure.
Securest Passwort ever.
Okay.
Jetzt scheint es funktioniert zu haben.
Unlock.
Was mich vielmehr interessiert ist,
wie die VM-Verwaltung und sowas aussieht.
Aber eigentlich ist es ganz cool gemacht.
Wie kann man da drüber auch
Samba-Shares oder sowas machen?
Lass mal gucken.
Networking.
Interfaces.
Add VPN.
Add Bond.
Add Team?
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung,
was ein Team ist.
Oh, es laggt.
Vodafone. Vodafone.
Was ist da los?
Ne, das laggt.
Das laggt an Twitch.
Ich habe keine Drop Frames gehabt.
RF Programmer.
Ja, aber dieses Ding startet gar nicht mehr.
Es gehen auch keine Lichter an und sowas.
Das kann eigentlich nicht sein,
dass es an Zertifikaten liegt.
Aber Bond ist das.
Warum gibt es ein Bond?
Und was ist da unten?
Okay, Linux Bond versus Team.
Okay, ich wusste nicht mal.
Bonding kenne ich.
Moment.
Cisco Benamung.
Was sich glaube ich
Port Aggregation nennt bei Cisco.
Ja, genau.
Comparison of Network Teaming to Bonding.
Okay.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Red Hat Seite.
User can set Hash Function.
Load Balancing
for LACP.
Warte mal, LACP sagt mir irgendwas.
Ist LACP diese
Geschichte mit automatischer
Auswahl anhand der MAC-Adresse
oder sowas?
Das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Ich bilde mir ein, wir haben das mal benutzt
auf irgendeinem HA-Proxy
Load Balancing Cluster.
Ist LACP diese Geschichte
mit diesem automatisch auswählen
anhand der MAC-Adresse?
Ne, ne, das ist Link Aggregation Protocol.
Ist wieder was anderes.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich keine Ahnung,
was der Unterschied ist.
Ist mir auch vollkommen egal.
Ich will weder ne Bridge noch
ein WLAN.
Ne Bridge können wir mal adden.
Gibt ja noch keine.
Brrrr.
Aber, kann das
Bridges und so anlegen?
Ifconfig best.
Ich brauch immer Ifconfig.
Ich benutze das immer noch.
Add Bridge. Probier mal aus hier.
Add. Bam.
Bridge am Start.
Was soll Debian Cockpit sein?
Debian ist, das ist Cockpit.
Wir probieren das auf Debian aus.
Cockpit ist eigenes.
Cockpit Project.
Das ist ein Web Interface zum Managen von Linux Servern.
Eigentlich braucht man es nicht.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen,
wenn man darüber Netzwerkshares anlegen kann.
Und
VMs verwalten ist das ganz nice.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier?
User Accounts.
Aber ich muss sagen,
das finde ich, es ist ganz gut gemacht.
Es erinnert vom Aufbau her
tatsächlich ein bisschen an Cloud Management
Web Interfaces
für VMs.
Ja, so wie bei DigitalOcean
zum Beispiel.
Wenn man da in den VM reinklickt, kann man ja auch mehr oder weniger
diesen Camper hier einstellen.
Services.
Achso, das sind die ganzen SystemD
Dinger.
So was würde ich halt alles nicht
über das Web Interface machen.
Da wird zum Beispiel SSH eingeloggt und gut ist.
Applications.
Ah, hier kann man Plugins installieren.
Oder wie?
Aber hier kann man
keine Plugins über das Web Interface installieren.
Das ist schon mal eine
verschenkte Chance.
Hier kann man seine
SSH Keys und so hinterlegen.
Moment, against other systems?
Hä?
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Boah!
Mein Auge.
Software Updates kann man machen.
Okay.
Cockpit mehrere Server fallen.
Und es gibt einen Web Terminal.
Brauchen wir alles, wenn man per SSH drauf kommt.
Was ich viel interessanter finde,
wie installiert man das?
Gibt es jetzt Search?
Cockpit. Gucken wir mal, was es da alles gibt.
Graptor.
Ja, hat sehr viel mit Cockpit zu tun, würde ich sagen.
Cockpit WS
Cockpit
Storage
Cockpit User Interface für
389 Directory Server
Okay, keine Ahnung, whatever
Was ist
300, es ist LDAP, okay
Dann installieren wir mal
Ähm, up, install
Cockpit Machines
Und Cockpit
Hotman
Gibt's mir, ich brauch
Mehr Packages, jawoll
Rein da
Gachi Roll
Ey Leute, für Frontend Developer
Ist das nix
Frontend Developer sind das gewohnt, erstmal das halbe Internet
Runterzuladen, außerdem
Ich verstehe schon, dass der zu managen
Von VM Slip wird und KVM
Und den ganzen Krempel braucht
Irgendwann muss das ja installiert werden
Ach, hier gibt es so eine Übersicht
Storage Network
Upgrade OS3
Based Systems in your Browser
Bin ich jetzt ein Kacknoob
Dafür, dass ich nicht weiß, was mit OS3
Gemeint ist
Vielleicht bin ich einfach zu jung
Vielleicht war das was von 1960
Was ist OS3 Based Systems
Portman Containers
SE Linux
Certificate Management
Interesting
Ih, man muss sowas selbst bauen
Was ist das
Assert Manager klingt
Das klingt gar nicht so übel
Aber das ist, ne Moment, das ist nur für lokale Sachen
Ich glaube, das ersetzt
Nicht irgendwie
Das ist nicht so übel, das ist nur für lokale Sachen
Ordentliches Zertifikatsmanagement
Ne, gab es nichts in den Repos
Diagnostics Support
Red Hat Developed
Cockpit Compose
Session Recording
Subscription
Natürlich, was sonst
Ovirt, da mache ich einen ganz großen Bogen drum
Third Party, ZFS Manager
File Sharing
Okay
Das probieren wir nochmal aus
Irgendwie einen Samba Share da drin anlegen und dann machen wir das auch wieder
Oder sowas
File Browser brauche ich nicht
Benchmark
Sensors
Tail Scale
Head Scale
Was ist Head Scale
Also Tail Scale ist das nicht das Cloudflare VPN
Rootless
Moment, redet ihr von Podman gerade
Podman läuft standardmäßig auch nicht Rootless, gell
Nur mal so angemerkt
Okay, im Prinzip ist das nicht so gut, ne?
Im Prinzip die interessantesten Sachen haben wir uns schon angeguckt
Also was wir noch ausprobieren werden gleich ist diese
File Sharing Geschichte
Ubuntu only
Wie, was ist das für ein Schrott
Warum kann man nicht
Okay, so, jetzt ist der Kram installed
Okay, man sieht auch, dass es da ist
Aber was haben wir denn jetzt zur Auswahl
Podman Containers
Virtual Machines
Was wollen wir uns zuerst angucken?
VMs oder Containers?
Wie kann man verschiedene Containers verwalten?
Wo man vielleicht auch zugemeistern kann
Wie man mit recognierem
Wo man auf einen eigenen einen
Da würde ich im privaten Bereich wahrscheinlich
Dar würde ich im privaten Bereich wahrscheinlich
Wenn ich jetzt nicht mal ein UnRaid hätte
Was ein Docker
Was ein Web-Interface schon hat für Container
Würde ich wahrscheinlich echt das Ding hier verwenden
Eine Web-Interface für Docker-Comp sewing-Files
Ich finde das ist eine coole Sache
Meine lineage kümmern beide selbstnell1616 удивacción
Was ich nicht machen werde
Meine Kansascheito die sindして
Oder einfach compose of this, das kann man auch genauso machen, ja klar.
Okay, lasst mal kurz, User is also, User Podman Service is also available, start.
Okay, create pod, create container.
Jetzt bin ich schon wieder komplett verwirrt, was der Unterschied sein soll.
Im Kubernetes Kontext weiß ich, was ein Pod ist.
Pod ist quasi eine Collection von Containern, könnte man sagen.
Im Kubernetes Cluster.
Pod ist quasi die kleinste gemanagte Einheit im Kubernetes Cluster.
Aber im, also die wollen ja, dass man eindeutig den Knopf drückt.
Weil der, der ist ja blau.
Also ein Pod ist ein Network, ne.
Ein Pod ist quasi so ein Sammelbecken für Container in Kubernetes.
Es ist schwer zu erklären.
Also, in Kubernetes denkst du ja meistens nicht auf Container-Ebene, sondern auf Anwendungs-Ebene.
Man könnte quasi sagen, ein Pod ist in der Regel eine Anwendung.
Zum Beispiel, nur mal so, warum das Sinn macht.
Stell dir mal vor, du hast, keine Ahnung, du hast eine Anwendung, du hast irgendeinen Web-Service, okay.
Ein Pod kann auch mehrere Container haben, ja, hab ich doch gerade gesagt.
Stell dir vor, du hast irgendeinen Web-Service.
Ein Interface für irgendwas, irgendeine Web-API oder so.
Die besteht aus drei Containern.
Das eine ist die eigentliche Web-API-Anwendung.
Das andere ist ein Proxy für die Datenbank-Verbindung.
Und das dritte ist ein Container, der Metriken bereitstellt.
Diese drei Container würdest du quasi reinpacken in einen Pod.
Das ist dann quasi das Ding, was du auch managen lässt von Kubernetes.
Also wenn du sagst, hier, ich will das, dass du das startest, dann startet er immer drei Container, weil Pod das kleinste ist, was er managen kann.
Also das, was man mit Compose macht, ist ein Pod.
Nee, Pod ist ein Kubernetes-Begriff.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das hier sein soll.
Postchamp, Podman.
Create Container in Pod.
Ist das vielleicht tatsächlich hier auch sowas ähnliches?
Ich check's, ich check's nicht.
Das braucht man wahrscheinlich nicht.
Delete.
Create Container machen wir jetzt.
Wir createn einen Container und zwar, wo kann man das Image auswählen?
Docker.
Die haben Docker.io direkt integriert.
Das finde ich schon mal ganz nice.
Man könnte vielleicht auch GitHub und so integrieren.
Da könnten wir jetzt den Fiat Champ starten.
Und, aber gucken wir mal.
Hello World.
Hello.
World.
Container.
Machen wir den Hello World Container.
Create and run.
Exited.
Ja, der macht nix.
Der startet und exited dann.
Logs.
Hello from Docker.
Okay, das ist eigentlich ganz cool gemacht, das Webinterface für so simple Sachen.
Nee, Odolmit.
Schick einen Link zu GitHub.
Wir können mal den Hello World Web Container.
Da gibt es doch so einen.
Oder war das dieser Traffic?
Hello World Web Traffic Docker Container.
Wie hieß der?
Wie hieß der denn?
Es gab so einen total simplen Hello World Web Interface Container, äh, Web API Container.
Ach, Who Am I hieß das Ding, genau.
Who, ja, ja, ja.
Okay, Create Container.
Warum muss man dem Ding Namen geben?
Who Am I?
Ja, das da, genau.
Memory Limit, CPU Shares, Create and Run.
Ja gut, aber wo hat man jetzt Ports und so ausgewählt?
Das ist, das ist dein Tool.
Aha.
Ja.
GitLab, warum nicht, warum, warum nicht auf GitHub?
War jetzt nur so blöd, weil auf GitHub wird man halt viel einfacher gefunden als auf GitLab.
Ähm, ey, das, Konsole gibt da bestimmt keine Shell drin, ja.
Wie, wie, wie editiert man das jetzt?
Gar nicht, oder wie?
Erstmal stoppen.
Irgendjemand eine Idee, wie man das jetzt editiert?
Oder, oder Ports, oder Ports weiterleitet?
Okay, deleten wir das Ganze nochmal.
Ach, hier.
Port Mapping.
Aha.
Restart Policy Always.
Warte.
Health Check.
Eigentlich, eigentlich auch ganz cool gemacht, das Web Interface davon, finde ich.
Jetzt so auf den ersten Blick ganz okay.
When Unhealthy Restart.
Integration.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich glaube, da kann man gar keinen richtigen, gescheiten Health Check machen.
So, Integration.
Integration.
Warum?
Warum Integration Port Mapping drunter ist, verstehe ich zwar nicht.
Ja, brauchen tut man es nicht, aber es ist nice gemacht, das schließt sich doch nicht aus.
Add Port Mapping.
Okay.
Äh, auf welchem, auf welchem Port läuft denn das standardmäßig?
Acht, wahrscheinlich 80, hä?
Was, IP-Adress? Brauche ich doch nicht.
Und All IPs, jawohl.
Post Port.
80? Ich hoffe mal 80.
80, 80.
70.
Create and run.
Bam.
Sieht man jetzt, dass man hier Ports weitergeleitet hat?
Nee.
Ach, hier.
Okay.
Heißt im Endeffekt, wenn ich jetzt hier drauf gehe, Port 80, also sofern das auf Port 80 läuft.
Hello World, ja.
Nice.
Kunst.
Also für so rudimentären Kram ist das doch ganz nice.
Wisst ihr, was richtig cool wäre, wenn man verschiedene...
Wenn man noch weitere Image-Registries hinzufügen könnte zum Durchsuchen.
Das wäre natürlich sehr, sehr nice, aber kann man wahrscheinlich nicht.
Oder vielleicht kann man hier in die...
Ah, da kommt man hier.
Ähm, gucken wir mal.
Cockpit, Portman.
Suchen wir mal nach Registry.
Vielleicht kann man da was...
Ja, sowas würde ich auch niemals remote auf dem Server verwenden.
Nee, okay, kann man nicht.
Aber für einen lokalen, irgendwie, HP-Micro-Server oder was auch immer die Leute da rumstehen haben, ist das doch nice.
Braucht man dafür wirklich eine Konzeptzeichnung?
Okay, hatte keiner Bock seit letztem Jahr.
Das würde ich aber auch weiterhin nicht über Cockpit machen.
So, warum man sich Red Hat ans Bein bindet?
Weil Enterprise Business gerne Support-Verträge macht.
Ich verstehe es auch nicht so recht.
Also ein bisschen rudimentäres Konzept.
Container starten und so, ist das hier eigentlich ganz okay.
So, ich bin mal gespannt, wie man die VM-Verwaltung ist.
Virtual Machines.
Okay, man sagt Import VM, was auch immer das machen soll.
Ach so, für Sachen, die schon da sind, okay.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie gut das gemacht ist.
Create VM.
Cloud-Based Image.
Äh, Debian?
Kann man nur Bullseye, ist auch ein bisschen outdated.
Okay, das ist ganz cool, dass man das hier customisieren kann.
Was mich viel...
Cloud?
Passt zu Cloud-Image?
Okay, und Debian Cloud-Image-Download.
Gute Frage, Chat.
Kann man ein Cloud-Init angeben?
Das wäre natürlich sehr nice.
So, wenn das funktionieren würde.
Aber anscheinend nicht.
Kann man vielleicht...
Cloud-Init-Cockpit.
Add support for Cloud-Init-Options.
Closed.
This was implemented.
Okay.
Ach so.
Ach, man kann nur die Credentials anpassen.
Man kann nicht einfach ein Cloud-Init oder sowas dranhängen.
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Das ist mal richtig viel verschenktes Potential.
Cloud-Init ist superpraktisch.
Also zum Beispiel...
Also unter anderem, was man über Cloud-Init machen kann, sind IP-Adressen einstellen oder SSH-Options setzen oder sowas.
SSH-Keys, genau.
Cloud-Init ist mega praktisch.
Es würde sogar reichen, wenn die einfach ein Feld unten drunter hätten.
Custom.
Options.
Dann würdest du eingeben, was Sache ist.
Ja.
Nicht so geil jetzt, oder?
Ich meine, außerdem ist es ziemlich outdated, overrated.
Ich meine, wenn da nur Debian...
Wenn da nicht mal Bookworm drin ist, sondern nur Debian Bullseye ist schon...
Ja, du kannst...
Man kann alles irgendwie selbst machen.
Aber wenn ich sowas verwende, will ich doch, dass es mir die Arbeit abnimmt.
Create and edit.
Ja, okay.
Oh, alles in Ordnung.
Install.
Nice.
Wie war das nochmal?
KVM?
What?
Ne.
Wird...
Wie kommt man das nochmal...
KVM, okay, war das doch, oder?
Wo man das checken konnte.
Gab's da nicht so...
Ja.
Was muss man dafür installieren?
CPU-Checker.
Ja.
Sehr intuitiv.
KVM-Accelerations can be used.
KVM exists.
Also, das müsste gehen.
Nö, hat keinen Bock.
Das ist ja schon mal ziemlich schrottig, oder?
Löschen wir das nochmal?
Das ist ja Müll.
Das braucht ja wirklich kein Mensch dann, ey.
Machen wir mal User-Session vielleicht.
Debian.
Automation hier.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Jetzt haben die auch noch so einen dummen Check.
It's too simplistic.
Ah, underscore.
What?
Okay.
Besser.
Bestes Passwort.
Moment, jetzt...
Jetzt funktioniert's?
Ah, ah.
Wie krieg ich ne Konsole hier?
Konsole.
Der sollte eigentlich...
Äh, oder geht's trotzdem jetzt?
Es könnte sein, dass es trotzdem geht.
Geht trotzdem.
Zeigt einfach nur Mist an.
Naja, gut.
So, ich glaub, wir haben eigentlich alles Notwendige gesehen.
So wahnsinnig überzeugt hat's mich jetzt.
Nicht...
Ehrlich gesagt.
Meine Uhr sagt mir gerade, dass ich entspannt schlafen soll, weil ich mich heute so angestrengt hab.
Na, Proxmox und Cockpit, das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen was Unterschiedliches, ne?
Proxmox ist rein für Virtualisierung ein bisschen Containerisierungssachen.
Mit Cockpit kannst du halt einen Custom-Linux-Server managen.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich bin an den Managed Features 0 interessiert.
Das Einzige, was mich da interessiert hat, ist...
Das Management von VMs und eventuell von Netzwerk-Shares.
Wobei ich da halt sagen muss, dieses Netzwerk-Share-Ding probier ich gar nicht aus, wenn die Debian nur unsupported haben.
Also, das hier ist schon ganz brauchbar gemacht.
Das Interface für VMs.
Aber so wirklich...
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob...
Seine Zielgruppe irgendwie findet das Ding.
Also, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wofür ich es verwenden soll, ehrlich gesagt.
Wie heißt...
Was für ein Ding?
Kennt ihr mal andere GUI als Virtual Manager?
Was?
Garnetti kenn ich nicht.
Was ist das?
GitHub Garnetti?
Virtual Machine Cluster Manager Tool Build und Top of Access...
Xen...
Oh, KVM.
Also, ganz ehrlich, wenn die Projekte schon so eine Readme haben und so eine Webseite...
Keine Screenshots und nix, also, dann weiß ich ja auch nicht.
Oh, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Sowas wird schnell verwenden.
Das sieht ja aus.
Das Auge ist mit, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Was ist Boxes?
Ach, du meinst Gnome Box als GUI.
Ja, aber so ein gescheites Webinterface wäre doch schon was.
Das hat mich jetzt alles nicht so überzeugt.
Wahrscheinlich bleibe ich am Ende jetzt wieder bei Unraid hängen.
Ne, es muss sich gut anfühlen beim Benutzen.
Und die Performance muss stimmen.
Ich finde beides wichtig.
Ne, Proxmox ist für meinen Anwendungszweck nix.
Ich will VMs.
Dafür wäre Proxmox gut.
Ich will aber auch Netzwerk-Share-Management und Raid.
Wobei ich, ehrlich gesagt, die, den Raid-Ansatz, den Unraid macht, ganz gut finde.
Das ist ja kein klassisches auf Block-Ebene Raid.
Das ist eher so ein großes Union-File-System über die einzelnen Disks.
Open Media Vault haben wir uns sogar im Stream schon angeguckt.
Ja, warum nicht?
Ich habe ja eine Lifetime-Lizenz.
Ne, Open Media Vault.
Open Media Vault gefällt mir nicht.
Open Media Vault mag ich nicht.
Ich mag auch TrueNAS nicht.
Dann wird es wahrscheinlich weiterhin Unraid bleiben.
Das stimmt.
Die Cockpit-GUI finde ich hübscher als von Unraid.
Dafür fehlt der Rest.
Also, ich werde bei Unraid bleiben.
Ja, TrueNAS Scale ist das auf Linux-Basis, oder?
Das haben wir ausprobiert.
Das andere haben wir gar nicht ausprobiert.
Wir haben nur das auf Linux-Basis ausprobiert.
Das, was für Container-Management einen eigenen Kubernetes-Lokal mitbringt und letztendlich
customisierte Helm-Charts anbietet, was ich sehr irgendwie befremdlich fand als Lösung.
Ne, ich schreibe keine Doku, weil der Kram funktioniert halt einfach.
Ja, doch, mache ich manchmal.
So Alibi-mäßig ab und zu.
Synology als VM?
Ja.
Ist auch eine coole Sache.
Du meinst X-Penology, oder wie das heißt, gell?
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool, aber das ist halt so ein halbs...
Also, eigentlich so ein unsupportetes Ding, wo du immer nicht weißt, wie lange es funktioniert.
Du willst Doku automatisieren?
Das ist ja auch mal ein guter Ansatz.
Ich meine, du kannst irgendeinen Build-Step bauen, der Docs generiert oder so.
Es ist halt nur die Frage, ob man mit den Docs dann was anfangen kann, ja?
Ja, das ist das Erste, woran ich auch...
Das ist das Erste, woran ich auch gerade gedacht habe, aber ich kenne dazu nichts.
Das hat doch nicht wirklich was mit Doku-Sachen zu tun, oder?
Das sagt mir was, Backstage.
Ist Backstage nicht so ein Ding, wo du auf Kubernetes-Basis deine Entwickler...
Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht mehr.
Wo du deine Entwickler quasi auf dein Kubernetes-Cluster drauflassen kannst
und die da easy ihre Anwendungen drauf deployen können, ohne dass du...
Ohne dass du...
Ohne dass sie irgendeinen Admin brauchen.
Ich krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht mehr zusammen, aber sowas in der Richtung ist das doch.
Nee.
Das ist jetzt diese Apple-Geschichte, ja?
Das kenne ich.
Aber das habe ich...
Vom Namen her, ja.
Das habe ich aber nicht angeguckt.
Ja, ich meine, Jammel ist schon ein bisschen schrottig, aber es ist erträglich.
Also ganz ehrlich, dadurch, dass Jammel so etabliert ist,
finde ich es eigentlich ganz gut.
Gut, dass es nicht ganz so kacke ist.
Und man sich einheitlich mehr oder weniger als überall für Jammel entschieden hat,
es hat da auch seine Vorteile.
Ja, das mit den Einrückungen finde ich in Jammel immer noch unglaublich doof.
Gerade, dass du Arrays am Anfang als erstes Element machen kannst
und die Sachen da drunter dann anders einrücken kannst
und sie trotzdem innerhalb von dem...
Da komme ich immer regelmäßig durcheinander.
Ja.
Also...
Ich bin ja der Meinung,
hätten sie mal JSON sinnvoll erweitert mit Kommentaren und sowas,
ein bisschen früher.
Mittlerweile geht das ja, aber auch nur, wenn du halt einen neueren Parser hast
und deine Software das unterstützt, halt eine neuere Version.
JSON mit Comments hätte voll und ganz ausgereicht
als Grundlage für Kubernetes-Config zum Beispiel.
Und ich finde ja, JSON durch die Klammern auch klarer zu lesen,
wo was startet und wo was aufhört.
Und dann finde ich, dass das ein bisschen...
Es haben eigentlich nur Kommentare gefehlt.
Das war alles...
JSON.
Ja.
So.
Nachdem wir Cockpit uns angeguckt haben und Cockpit für...
ganz nett, aber ich wüsste nicht, wofür ich es verwenden soll...
haben.
Was haltet ihr davon, wenn wir uns jetzt noch das Video angucken?
Ach so, nee.
Erstmal gucken wir uns das Projekt von...
Wer war das?
Chatge?
Wer von euch?
War das mit dem Projekt?
Können wir uns das mal kurz angucken?
Wer war das?
Ich hab das doch so in der History bestimmt irgendwo.
Flip it.
Odolmet 3 ist das gewesen.
Wenn er noch da ist.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an.
Aber vorher...
Wie die Zahnpasta, ja.
Aber vorher löschen wir Jepp Cockpit und den Ordner.
Sonst vergesse ich das nämlich wieder und hab...
unnötigerweise bei mir auf der Platte.
So, also was hat er denn hier programmiert?
Er wollte ein bisschen Werbung machen für seine Software.
A bundle of command line tools to copy contents to the clipboard free from bullshit.
War eher gut.
Man könnte auch Xclip oder so benutzen oder oder.
Wie heißen diese drei Dinger unter Linux, die es standardmäßig gibt?
Xclip.
Es gibt so drei Dinger.
Eins davon hat jeder auf dem Rechner.
Ach so.
Ist das written in Rust?
Ah, written in Rust.
Okay, jetzt verstehe ich die Daseinsberechtigung.
Natürlich.
Es ist X.
Es ist Xclip written in Rust.
Okay, man kann Sachen pipen nach Clip.
Clip F kann man ohne, ohne useless use of cat kann man.
Der Teil ins Clipboard pasten.
Ja, nice.
Also so als Übungsprojekt ist das ganz cool.
Meiner persönlichen Meinung nach braucht es halt niemand, weil du einfach Xclip verwenden kannst.
Aber.
Why not?
Der Source Code hält sich auch sehr in Grenzen, oder?
Ja, ich habe mir das gerade angeguckt.
Das Ding ist also als Übungsprojekt finde ich das eigentlich ganz nice.
Das Ding ist, warum?
Warum sollte ich das verwenden, anstatt einfach Xclip oder das andere Zeug, was standardmäßig mit dabei ist?
Ach so, weil es unter Windows funktioniert.
Okay, da gebe ich dir ja für Windows ist es nice.
Windows hat ja sowas nicht.
Für Windows finde ich cool.
Man.
Der Source Code hält sich auch in Grenzen.
Der Source Code hält sich auch enorm in Grenzen.
Ich habe es mir gerade angeguckt.
Letztendlich du hast hier eine Clipboard Handle Library da drinnen und und ja, die wird aufgerufen.
Für Windows stelle ich es mir tatsächlich ganz cool vor.
Für Linux muss ich sagen.
But why?
Außer dass es written in Rust ist, aber die ganzen Krustentiere freuen sich bestimmt blazingly fast.
Ja, okay, ich gebe zu, es ist enorm wichtig, dass ich den.
Den Text, ja, Echo 1, 2, 3, ob ich den jetzt in 5 oder 4 Millisekunden im Clipboard habe, das stimmt schon.
Das ist sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig.
Ja, warum man zwei Binarys braucht, verstehe ich tatsächlich auch nicht, ja.
Man könnte das auch einfach in Clip einbauen.
Man, man, man ruft Clip auf mit, mit dem Pfeil hinten dran.
Also Leute, was wir uns noch angucken können, weil ich habe es ja vorher schon ein bisschen, schon ein bisschen drüber geflankt.
Was, was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Katzenmeme News, ja, irgendwie sowas.
Wie viel RAM verbraucht denn Chrome gerade?
Wir haben das schon öfters nachgeguckt.
Es ist nicht so viel, weil die meisten Tabs inaktiv sind.
Können wir machen, aber es ist nicht viel.
Ja.
Guck mal, ist fast nix.
1,1 Gig.
Das ist nix.
Und dann kommt Chrome.
Chrome.
Chrome selbst noch dabei.
Das hat nochmal 900.
Das ist nix.
Die meisten Tabs sind ja, genau, die sind im Bett gemacht, die Tabs.
Hier.
Genau.
Okay.
Wenn wir es gerade davon hatten, Kubernetes hosten bei sich daheim.
Ich, wir skippen da mal kurz durch, weil 40 Minuten gucke ich mir da jetzt nicht an.
Ich glaube, es ist wahrscheinlich auch nur der Anfang interessant.
Weil.
Alter.
Der übertreibt es wieder so krass, Mann.
Da habe ich das letzte Mal schon gesagt, ich verstehe den Sinn davon absolut gar nicht.
Okay.
Auf geht's.
Also eins muss man eben sagen.
Es ist ein sehr schön beleuchtetes Rack.
Wisst ihr jetzt, wo ich mir das so angucke?
Ich fände Beleuchtung in Racks selber.
Eigentlich auch eine coole Sache.
Normalerweise ist es im Rechenzentrum drumherum halt auch von der Deckenbeleuchtung und so
so hell, dass man es nicht braucht.
Aber so eine Beleuchtung im Rack wäre cool.
Warum?
Warum hat er da?
Was hat er da?
Was bin ich da überhaupt alles sehend?
Tree Machine kommt mir nicht ins Haus.
Enterprise Dings.
Ubiquiti.
Budweiser.
US.
Ich weiß.
Ich.
Okay.
Nein.
Das ist.
Nein da.
Was ist denn das hier?
Uspdings?
Was auch immer.
Ist das die Ubiquiti.
Äh.
Usv da unten?
Das ist mit Sicherheit teuer.
Zumindest hat er mindestens mal 10 GB teilweise.
Muss nicht.
Aber wahrscheinlich.
Das ist Power Distribution, aber es heißt USp.
Also, uninterruptible Power supply?
Ja.
Supply.
Nur falsch rum geschrieben.
Ihr kriegt Glasfaser, bei mir sind sie
nicht so schnell mit dem Ausbau.
Ich bin heute wieder
vorbeigelaufen in so ein paar kleinen Orten bei uns
und drumherum, da wird überall fleißig ausgebaut.
Okay, lass mal gucken.
Ja.
Dashboards!
Dafür brauchst du definitiv ein Rack mit
Netzwerkequipment.
Und was zum Teufel
hat der da alles laufen?
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
für die Menge an Hardware
sind jetzt ja
VMs
pro Virtualisierungs-
Node jetzt auch
nicht wirklich die Welt.
Ey, sagt das
Sebaroma, äh, nicht Sebaroma,
doch, Sebaroma.
Die haben doch auch irgendein eigenes
AS für
ein IPv6-AS,
worüber jetzt
die Archivseite von mir läuft.
Autonomos System.
Auto, ich kann das nicht aussprechen.
Das ist das, wie im Internet
gerautet wird.
Wie man das in seinen Keller bekommt,
würde mich auch interessieren, ja.
Weil der Sebaro hat es nicht im Keller.
Das haben wir uns schon angeguckt, ja.
Das wurde für
ganz cool,
aber irgendwie
überflüssig befunden.
Okay, lasst mal gucken, also.
Sekunde.
Das ist im Endeffekt
das Unify-Controller-Ding, oder?
Ja, klar, natürlich.
Was sonst?
Äh.
Was hat er denn hier am Start?
Was sehe ich da?
Was ist das, Leute?
Ist das Rancher?
Okay, das, das, das.
Ewig, ne, mal gesehen.
85 Pots
aus
39 Deployments
und 4 Stateful-Sets.
What the fuck? Was hat der da laufen, man?
39 Deployments, so viel
habe ich auf unserem produktiven Kubernetes
nicht mal drauf.
GitOps, to CI and CD,
to multiple reverse proxies,
monitoring and data visual.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Die eigentlichen Sachen, die da drauf laufen, ja.
Habe ich jetzt nichts gesehen,
außer einen Pi-Hole
für DNS-Adblocking.
Der Rest war Management fürs Management
des Managements. Okay.
Äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh.
Uptime-Kuma fürs Monitoring.
Das könntest du legit
sogar alles auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen lassen.
Und das Dashboard.
Okay, Home Assistant auch.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
... Network Diagrams
as well as logical diagrams
for where everything lives.
To help you understand how this all comes together.
That's why I was a little bit late getting it out.
Aber ich frage jetzt, hat er Monitoring für Monitoring?
... See more about this diagram.
I'll have links below in the description.
So let's take a look at everything
that I'm self-hosting in my home lab.
First, let me show you how my network is laid out.
Now, before you go accusing me
of just taking free stuff from Ubiquity,
I purchased all of these things
you see on here, with the exception of
one thing, and it was this one switch,
which replaced an existing
48-port switch.
But this is my UDMSE.
The Internet comes into here.
This is my firewall and my gateway.
And it manages all of my VLANs.
Then connected to this
is my switch aggregation pro,
which you saw in the hardware tour.
And then from there, I have the 48-port switch
uplinked to there, as well as
this 24-port PoE switch
that's in here in the studio, uplinked to there.
This one's uplinked at 20 gig.
Really, it's a lag of two 10 gigs.
And this one's uplinked at 10 gig.
...
Was macht der denn da mit
10 Gig?
Mein 10 Gig alleine ist
nice, aber fragt man sich,
was da dranhängt.
Hier sieht man
im Endeffekt hängen ein paar Access Points
und Kameras dran.
Wir scrollen mal ein bisschen vor.
Leute, ich verstehe,
dass das seinen Reiz hat.
Ich bin auch Bastler. Ich bastel unglaublich gerne
und ich frickel auch dran rum,
bis es funktioniert.
Aber ich verstehe schon,
dass es einen gewissen Reiz hat.
Auch wenn man das dann alles so schön hier im Diagramm hat
und sich das angucken kann,
da geht einem schon ein bisschen einer drauf ab.
Aber ich habe das bei mir alles daheim
radikal vereinfacht.
...
Ich will jetzt eigentlich nur sehen,
was da wirklich drauf läuft.
Ich kann es nicht kommentieren,
weil das ist ein Blogpost
von fünf Seiten.
...
Ich kann es nicht kommentieren,
weil das ist ein Blogpost von fünf Seiten.
...
Ich sage Kubernetes Node?
Was macht der da?
...
Okay, weiter, weiter, weiter.
Alter, wie viele, wie viele verschiedenen, ich dachte, meint sich schon übertrieben.
Ich glaube, ich glaube nämlich, mein Netzwerk ist eigentlich das komplizierteste an meinem ganzen Setup hier.
Aber das habe ich halt wegen den ganzen IoT-Geräten.
Ich meine, ich habe ein eigenes IoT-WLAN, ein normales für Client-Geräte, die aber über das WLAN reinkommen,
WLAN und ein internes, fertig.
Also ein Default-WLAN quasi.
Das war es eigentlich.
Das ist wahrscheinlich schon mehr, als die meisten Leute daheim haben.
Aber das finde ich noch irgendwie sinnig.
Gerade mit den ganzen IoT-Geräten.
Die willst du eigentlich nicht im normalen Netzwerk haben.
Was für einen Router Firewall benutzt du?
Einen ganz billigen MikroTik Hex PoE.
Für 50 Euro.
So ein Teil hier.
Das reicht halt dicke.
Ich habe da insgesamt, was weiß ich, 20 Firewall-Regeln drin.
Da lacht es sich drüber kaputt.
Drei oder vier WLANs.
Ich glaube, drei sogar.
Nur, fertig.
An den PoE-Ports hängen zwei Access-Points.
Was sagst du, so lange kommen keine Erfahrungen mit.
Also es hängen zwei Access-Points dran.
An den PoE-Ports.
Dann hängt der interne Switch dran.
Der wird aber nicht PoE-versorgt.
Und der Uplink zum Provider-Modem hängt dran.
Das war es.
Reicht.
Dann habe ich viele IOT-Devices und das sind viele der Devices, die du wahrscheinlich hier sehen wirst.
Wann geht es denn eigentlich los?
Wann geht es denn hier los?
Okay.
Hier geht es los, was er eigentlich benutzt.
... in einige dieser Services, die in diesen verschiedenen WLANs funktionieren.
Also zuerst fangen wir mit dem Dashboard an.
Es ist immer noch Heimdall.
Heimdall ist ein tolles Produkt.
Ich denke...
Ja.
Das finde ich auch ganz nice.
Das habe ich auch bei mir.
Ja.
Ich benutze das so gut wie nie, das Dashboard.
Ich habe es irgendwann mal eingerichtet, weil ich es cool fand.
Aber eigentlich braucht man gar kein Dashboard, wenn man mal ehrlich ist.
Wozu braucht man ein Dashboard?
Man kann sich die Services einfach bookmarken.
Gut, dann werden wir mal vielleicht doch vom Handy drauf...
Was auch immer.
Man kann sich die Dinge auf seinem Desktop einfach bookmarken.
Ja.
Oder eben halt einfach in der Browserleiste eingeben, wo man hin will, wenn man sinnvolle DNS-Namen hat.
Ich habe auch ein Dashboard mal eingerichtet, weil es cool aussieht, aber ich benutze das nicht.
Was hat er denn hier am Start?
Wir filtern jetzt mal alles raus, was nur Infrastruktur und Management ist.
Management, Management, Management, Infrastruktur, NAS...
Okay, das zähle ich mit.
Das ist okay.
Quasi NAS-Software laufen, das ist in Ordnung.
Rancher, Infrastruktur...
Lange...
Alter.
Das ist so Distributed Storage.
So.
Infrastruktur, Infrastruktur, Infra...
Vier Proxmox-Skills.
Schlink, das ist irgendein Url-Shortener.
Drei Pi-Holes.
MinIO, bin ich mir jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr sicher, was das ist aus dem Kopf.
Chat, wisst ihr das?
Ist das irgendein Media-Server oder was ist das?
Ach, S3.
S3-Storage.
Hat er auch noch dabei, okay.
Also im Prinzip auch Management.
Portena, ja, wahrscheinlich auch Management-Gram.
Ich persönlich mag Portena überhaupt gar nicht.
Home-Assist, okay, das zählt.
Haben wir jetzt quasi schon vier Sachen, die gehostet werden.
Pi-KVM, ja, okay.
Management im Endeffekt.
Okay, Monitoring 5, Plex 6.
Weiß ich nicht, was das ist.
Ist das E-Book-Download?
Kann das sein?
Brotlink-Control, das ist für diese kleinen Brotlink-Infrarotsender.
Da wüsste ich aber auch nicht, wo man hin will.
Monitoring, Monitoring-Look, kenne ich nicht.
Das ist DVB-C, Fernsehgucken.
Netboot, Traffic, Storinator.
Okay, er ist im Prinzip, hat er so fünf oder sechs Services da drauf laufen,
die eigentlich auch alle auf dem Raspberry Pi haben.
Die eigentlich auch alle auf dem Raspberry Pi auf einem laufen könnten.
Das Einzige, wo man sich jetzt vielleicht sagt, okay, wenn man da wirklich ausgiebig was macht,
ist TrueNAS.
TrueNAS verstehe ich, wenn man sagt, ey, dafür eine eigene Kiste.
Okay, mit ordentlich Anbindung und ein paar SSDs drin und sowas.
Sinnig, okay.
Und dann braucht man halt auch kein Raspberry Pi,
dann kann man den anderen Kram da drauf laufen lassen im Endeffekt.
Also eigentlich, eigentlich würde es...
eine Kiste tun,
die vielleicht nächtlich mal auf eine externe Platte gesynct wird
und gut ist.
Weil eine Sache...
Also es geht ihm eindeutig nicht um die Services,
sondern wahrscheinlich eher ums Lernen und ums Content produzieren dafür.
Nichts Verwerfliches dran.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Mist.
Was habe ich gerade angefangen?
Die...
Fuck, jetzt ist...
Jetzt habe ich es ver...
verpeilt.
Was wollte ich denn?
Ich wollte gerade noch irgendwas dazu sagen.
Dann habe ich mich ablenken lassen.
Ich habe gesagt, man könnte es auch auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen lassen,
das wahrscheinlich nicht.
Auf der TrueNAS-Kiste und auf der TrueNAS-Kiste könnte man alles laufen lassen.
Ja, ein Raspberry Pi mit SSD dran höchstens, aber...
Also das auf einer eigenen Kiste und dann alles auf die eigene Kiste und gut ist.
Home Assistant, ja, mal gucken.
Ach so, jetzt weiß ich wieder.
Ja, Backup.
Also, jetzt weiß ich wieder, was ich sagen wollte.
Also, das Ding ist,
mal angenommen,
wenn man das jetzt mal gegenüberstellt hier,
die zwei Racks mit voll und...
viermal...
viermal Proxmox und alles,
das ist zwar,
nennen wir das mal hochverfügbar,
aufgebaut und sehr cool alles, ja.
Man darf aber eine Sache nicht vergessen.
Hochverfügbarkeit und...
bringt Komplexität und Komplexität
kann auch zu Ausfällen führen.
Also nur, weil was hochverfügbar aufgebaut ist,
heißt das nicht zwangsläufig,
dass das...
in reinen Zahlen...
hochverfügbarer ist automatisch.
Wisst ihr, wie ich das meine?
Wenn du vier, fünf Sachen hast, die ineinandergreifen,
die zwar hochverfügbar sind, aber alle irgendwie ordentlich konfiguriert sein müssen,
dann ist die Chance, dass da was kaputt geht
und dass du anwendungstechnisch irgendwas verkackst,
viel höher,
wie bei einer Kiste mit einer externen USB-Festplatte dran,
wo nächtlich mal ein AirSync draufläuft.
Ja, und ich hab das...
ich hab das im letzten Job auch öfters gesehen,
dass dort dann halt die Sachen hochverfügbar gebaut wurden,
aber Ausfälle gab's nicht dadurch,
dass das Netzwerk wirklich kaputt gegangen ist.
Also zum Beispiel gab es dort
HA-Proxy-Cluster
auf Linux-Basis
beim letzten Arbeitgeber, wo ich war.
Die haben... die standen richtig auf HA-Proxy.
Und...
das war alles schön geclustert und sonst was.
Wir hatten aber
seltenst...
ich kann mich jetzt an keinen größeren
Netzwerkausfall erinnern,
der wirklich durch Hardware-Defekte
ausgelöst wurde.
Ich kann mich an Netzwerk-Konfigurationsfehler erinnern,
wo das Netzwerk kaputt war.
Und ich kann mich daran erinnern
an HA-Proxy-Konfigurationsfehler
und an Keep-Alive-Konfigurationsfehler
und solche Geschichten.
Ja, das war noch ganz klassischer Linux-Cluster
mit Keep-Alive und diesem komischen...
Ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt,
diesem Load-Balancing anhand der MAC-Adresse.
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, wie das...
Weiß das jemand von euch?
Ich hab's voll verdrängt.
Es gibt so eine Möglichkeit,
dass du die Pakete vom Switch
an drei Server schicken lassen kannst
und die Server untereinander
haben irgendwie so einen Algorithmus,
dass sich immer nur einer von allen drei
dafür angesprochen fühlt.
Und das irgendwie anhand der MAC-Adresse.
Ich krieg's nicht mehr genau zusammen.
Das ist schon ewig her.
Also wir hatten fast nur Ausfälle
durch menschliche Konfigurationsfehler.
Nicht wirklich durch Hardware-Fehler.
Und deswegen bei solchen Setups
darf man das nie vergessen,
dass man im Zweifelsfall sich durch sowas
so viel Komplexität ins Haus holt,
dass du das als Vollzeit-Jobs machen kannst.
Gab's dort ein Staging-Environment?
Ja, klar.
Aber manche Sachen sind da nicht richtig aufgefallen.
Und deswegen ist es manchmal,
gerade im Heimbereich,
durchaus sinnvoll,
es simpel zu halten.
Eine Kiste mit externer USB-Festplatte dran,
wo nächtlich die Sachen
per AirSync drauf gebackupt werden.
Das muss nicht AirSync sein.
Da könnt ihr doch irgendwas anderes für verwenden.
Das ist super easy.
Du kannst theoretisch sogar überwachen,
ob deine Backups gelaufen sind.
Mit dem Monitoring-Tool deiner Wahl.
Kannst sogar irgendwas für Uptime-Kuma stricken,
was ja im Heimbereich ganz beliebt ist
mit diesem Push-Monitor.
Und dann ist alles gut. Das ist easy.
Und wenn dann wirklich mal der Fall der Fälle eintritt,
dass deine Kiste verreckt,
man muss ja sagen,
es kann immer mal passieren,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so,
als hätte die Hardware,
die man im Heimbereich verwendet,
irgendwie super krasse Fehler raten oder so.
Wem ist schon mal,
Chat,
Wem ist schon jemals
eine CPU kaputt gegangen,
wohlgemerkt nicht übertaktet oder irgendwelche Dinger gemacht,
so nach dem Motto, heute geht sie, morgen ist sie kaputt.
CPUs gehen so gut wie nicht kaputt.
Das einzige was kaputt geht an Hardware
ist so Sachen wie
Festplatten.
Und
ich meine im Heimbereich,
vielleicht, vielleicht mal
irgend so ein billig China-Chinesen-Netzteil
oder so, aber gescheite Netzteile
sind mir im privaten Bereich ehrlich gesagt noch nie
kaputt in 30 Jahren
oder nein, nicht ganz,
25 Jahren
noch nicht kaputt gegangen.
Festplatten, ja, Festplatten sind mir schon ein paar
kaputt gegangen.
Und SSDs
halten bei mir auch.
Und deswegen
muss man sich halt fragen, will man diesen ganzen
großen Aufwand machen versus
im Fall der Fälle,
ja, das ist ein gutes
Beispiel, USB.
Ich hatte jahrelang eine USB dran bei mir
im Rack und
den einzigen Ausfall in den letzten
Jahren hatte ich, als die USB kaputt
gegangen ist, nicht durch den Stromausfall.
Mittlerweile habe ich auch wieder
eine USB dran.
Eine relativ günstige
APC-USV, das letzte war
eine Cyberpower-USV.
Relativ günstige
APC-USV, die man
aber Hotswap die Batterie wechseln
kann, sollte die mal wirklich kaputt gehen.
Sonst habe ich da aber auch nichts
Großartiges. Und
ich mache einfach
nächtlich einen AirSync
auf eine externe Platte als Backup
und gut ist. Und wenn jetzt wirklich
mal der Fall der Fälle eintritt,
dass der HP
Microserver kaputt geht,
sagen wir mal echt,
das Netzteil geht kaputt und
grillt das Mainboard.
Zwar nicht sonderlich wahrscheinlich,
aber tun wir mal so,
als wäre es so. Was kann im
schlimmsten Fall passieren?
Das Ding ist dann halt mal für
zwei, drei Tage
weg, bis ich mir bei Amazon einen neuen bestellt
habe und bis ich
dort wieder an...
Theoretisch, ich kann den
USB-Stick abstecken und sogar auf das
neue Mainboard stecken und dann
bootet das wieder. Das heißt
im Endeffekt, ich mache die Platten aus dem alten
raus, stecke die ins neue,
mache den USB-Stick dran
und bootet den.
Und sollten die Platten
irgendwas abbekommen haben, dann
kopiere ich das Backup. Also im schlimmsten
Fall habe ich
drei, vier Tage
Ausfall.
Aber das meiste davon auch, weil
ich mir neue Hardware bei Amazon bestellen muss.
Und
ich denke, das ist im Heimbereich
durchaus vertretbar.
Dadurch,
wenn man als Alternative
hat, ich
brauche
quasi einen zweiten Job, um mich um
meine Heiminfrastruktur zu kümmern.
Du bootest von
USB? Ja. Das
System, das ist ein
Linux, das bootet von
USB, schreibt alles in
RAM und
benutzt den USB-Stick dann nicht mehr.
Nein, mein Router ist nicht
auf dem Server.
Es ist Unraid, ja.
Auch wenn ich, ich habe es ja am Anfang
gesagt, nicht ganz happy damit bin, aber es
tut. Ja, Home Assistant
down wäre doof,
aber letztendlich, ich habe ja noch Schalter.
Also für drei, vier Tage geht das noch.
Wäre schon ein bisschen
blöd, aber ich habe das bei mir daheim ja auch
alles ein bisschen dezentralisiert.
Ich hatte mal vor einer ganzen Weile, war
so, warum magst du Unraid nicht? Ich bin auch
kein Ultra-Unraid-Fan.
Würde mich interessieren, warum du das nicht magst.
Also ich habe ja am Anfang
des Streams schon ein paar Sachen gesagt, die mir nicht gefallen.
Zum Beispiel, dass sie
immer ewig lange brauchen mit Updates.
Ja, also
ich habe das ja bei mir
auch ein bisschen aufgesplittert. Ich hatte
vor Jahren mal so eine fette Kiste
hier stehen. Die sieht man sogar
in einem der...
Moment, das ist ja noch, das ist ja ganz alt
noch, Mann. Das ist ja ganz
alt. Das ist 2013,
Mann.
Porgas Kabelmanager.
Management.
Ja, hier unten sieht man das Ding noch.
Da hatte ich so eine 4HE, fette 4HE
Kiste drinne, bei mir im Rack.
Vor ein paar Jahren noch.
Aber natürlich mit
den guten Noctua-Lüftern.
Logisch. Was sonst?
Und ich hatte da
alles mögliche drauf, ja. Alles.
Also Fileserver
mit ZFS damals noch und irgendwie
sechs Festplatten.
Ein
OpenSense-Netzwerk.
Router, Kram.
Alles.
Fernsehempfang für meine Mutter damals noch.
Die hat
DVB-T gestreamt über das
Ding dann.
Und irgendwann
habe ich mir gedacht, okay,
du kannst die Kiste eigentlich nicht
rebooten, weil dann irgendwas nicht funktioniert.
Noch nicht mal dein Internet geht
dann. Deswegen habe ich dann
irgendwann angefangen, die Teile
etwas zu dezentralisieren.
Und
jetzt habe ich im Endeffekt
man sieht das hier
und natürlich
der Werkzeug Flex am Anfang, der muss sein.
Aber ich zeige hier gar nicht so viel.
Okay, da sieht man den 3D-Drucker oben drauf.
Letztendlich hängt da noch ein Switch
und
ach guck mal, da hatte ich noch die alte Kiste.
Da hatte ich noch
die alte 2HE Kiste.
Die habe ich gar nicht mehr.
Ich habe jetzt einen HP Microserver
stehen bei mir im Rack.
Das habe ich glaube ich nirgendswo aufgenommen.
Zumindest ist
das jetzt ein bisschen dezentralisiert. Internet
geht über das Provider-Modem
an meinen
Mikrotik-Router.
Und
Fernsehstreaming-Sachen macht
so eine Box im Wohnzimmer.
Weder an Access-Points habe ich
hier einen unten im Erdgeschoss, einen im ersten
Stock. Und
ja, es ist immer noch
relativ viel zentral,
was Heimautomatisierung angeht,
aber irgendwo muss der Kram halt laufen.
Letztendlich.
Und
wenn der
HP Microserver bei mir abkackt,
das nervigste, was nicht geht, ist
tatsächlich
die Heimautomatisierung.
Und die Netzwerkshares, die werden
dann erstmal weg, aber die Daten werden ja noch da.
Also nicht so wild.
Heimautomatisierung ist eigentlich wirklich die hauptsächliche
Sache, die nicht geht. Das heißt, wir könnten
keine Kameras
mehr gucken.
Die Heizung würde sich nicht mehr einschalten
morgens und sowas. Automatisch.
Man kann sie immer noch manuell einschalten.
Ja, aber das war's
im Endeffekt dann auch.
Also
nicht so wild.
Na gut, wir gucken jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter.
Wie viel Strom zieht dein Setup?
Unter 100 Watt
das komplette Rack.
Das komplette Rack braucht glaube ich 80 Watt oder sowas.
Oder noch weniger
mittlerweile. Ich habe eine Weile nicht mehr
gemessen. Das ist echt
stromsparend
geworden.
Mittlerweile.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht, das Ding.
Das ist nicht das allerneueste.
Von der Technik her dementsprechend.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht gewesen,
das Ding vom Stromverbrauch.
Ich meine, da sind zwei Platten drin, die sind aber immer
runtergespinnt.
Und SSD und...
Wahrscheinlich wird das Ding, was weiß ich,
18 Watt brauchen
oder so.
Beides. Na gut.
Das ist meine Meinung dazu.
Letztendlich kann natürlich trotzdem jeder
so bauen, wie er will.
So, also jetzt erzählt er uns, was er laufen hat.
Also 90%
von dem, was er laufen hat, ist halt
Infrastruktur und
Infrastruktur für die Infrastruktur.
Hat der Micro...
Microserver Remote Management, also
ILO. Ich glaube nicht.
Ne.
Ne, hat er nicht.
Hat er nicht.
Ich glaube, es gibt...
Ich glaube, es gibt so eine Zusatzkarte
dafür.
Ne, der hat keinen.
Also, meiner hat keinen Remote Management.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm.
Weißt du, warum?
Ich brauch kein Remote Management.
Ich hab mir vor Jahren
so ein Ding hier gekauft.
X...
Spider.
Ja. Vor Jahren hab ich mir
mal so ein Ding gekauft.
Bei Ebay.
Damals super günstig, noch irgendwie für 70
Euro oder so. Mittlerweile
kosten die Dinger ja Schweinegeld.
Und das ist quasi so
ein Mini-Netzwerk
KVM-Switch.
Kann man nicht wirklich KVM-Switch nennen,
weil der geht nur an eine Kiste dran.
Aber den stöpselst du dran
und dann kannst du dann selber Remote steuern.
Und eins muss man denen ja
immer wirklich zugute halten.
Die Hardware, das Ding,
das ist...
Ja, jetzt pass mal auf.
Das Ding, das ist von
2006 oder so.
Das ist uralt.
Das ist 15 Jahre alt, mindestens.
20 Jahre. Das ist uralt, das Teil.
Ja. Aber,
die haben vor ein paar Jahren ein Update
rausgebracht, dass das Web Interface
mit HTML5 und JavaScript läuft.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die das
gemacht haben.
Aber sie haben es gemacht.
Guck mal hier. Man findet die ersten Sachen von
2013 und so. Das ist aber
noch älter. Das ist uralt,
man. Weiß nicht, ob man das irgendwie
rausfindet.
2006. Es hat auch nur
einen 100-Mbit-Port.
Okay. Irgendwelche komischen Zertifikate.
Das gibt es nur bei
Software Release, oder?
Das gibt es von... Okay.
2014.
Das ist älter. Ich habe das jetzt ja schon
ein paar Jahre. Hier.
Okay, das sind neuere Sachen.
Ja. Das ist
wirklich... Das ist uralt.
Ich brauche mittlerweile einen fucking
Account für, man.
Zumindest haben die letztens das geupdatet.
Da war ich echt begeistert, weil ich mir gedacht habe,
man, siehst du mal, das Ding ist irgendwie
20 Jahre raus und die bringen noch ein HTML5
Update. Krasse Dudes.
So,
jetzt aber mal gucken, was da eigentlich laufen hat.
The fuck, Alter.
So viel Zeug da, man.
Für
letztendlich fünf Services.
Ich brauche mehr
Availabilität, wenn ich kann.
Also habe ich höhere Availabilität
an Services, anstatt an Virtual-Maschinen.
Ich mache es nur einen Schritt niedriger.
Aber, sowas. Stornator.
Das ist das große Stornator-Device, das du in der Rack gesehen hast.
Das hat auch Virtual-Maschinen.
Okay.
Das muss ein geiler Storage-Server sein.
Mit dem Painting
und RGB-Lüftern.
Stornator-Device, das du in der Rack gesehen hast.
Das hat auch Virtual-Maschinen.
Die größte Virtual-Maschine, die es bisher hatte,
war das Andromeda.
Das war meine virtualisierte TrueNAS.
Aber ich habe von der virtualisierten TrueNAS
zu einer physischen TrueNAS mit der HL15 gewechselt.
Wir sprechen darüber später.
Natürlich.
Für den Heimgebrauch muss schon sein.
So eine NAS-VM
hat einfach nicht die Performance,
die man braucht.
Logisch.
Das, was Stornator tun muss,
ist ein bisschen abwechslungsreich.
Wir sprechen darüber später.
Aber ich habe einige Virtual-Maschinen für Testen.
Schauen wir mal.
1, 2, 3.
Das sind Xing 1, 2 und 3.
Also habe ich all meine Geräte
zu diesen Intel NUCs gewechselt.
Okay.
Das finde ich eine interessante Sache.
Ich dachte,
da hat er jetzt super fette Kisten stehen.
Das ist ein Setup,
das lasse ich mir noch gefallen.
Also für sich genommen,
lasse ich mir das noch gefallen.
Drei triple Node
Proxmox Cluster mit drei Intel NUCs.
Das Storage kommt wahrscheinlich
über das Netzwerk.
Weil, wie sonst?
Die Dinger können ja außer, glaube ich,
eine NVMe nicht viel schlucken.
Halt höchstens USB.
Aber für USB-Storage,
das ist eben zu nubig.
Das geht auf jeden Fall über das Netzwerk.
Oder,
aber...
Ja, ne.
Fiber-Channel kriegst du auch nicht rein in die NUCs.
Also es muss über das Netzwerk gehen.
Und sie laufen hier.
Und so habe ich...
ISCSI oder was auch immer man da so
verwendet für
NFS.
Keine Ahnung.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 Virtual Machines.
Sie können hier sehen, sie laufen alle gut.
Sie können sehen, die CPU-Ausgabe ist ziemlich gut.
8 CPUs oder 8 Logical Cores auf jeder dieser.
IODelay ist ziemlich niedrig.
Ja, wirklich.
Auslastung haben die ja auch nicht.
Wow. Alter.
54 GB RAM-Usage.
Was passiert denn da gerade drauf?
Ach, Moment.
Moment.
Das ist der Node.
Ich dachte, das ist die erste VM.
Ich wollte gerade sagen,
dass der Node so eine hohe RAM-Auslastung hat,
wundert mich nicht.
ZFS nimmt sich ja alles, was es kriegen kann.
Wobei das nicht stimmt.
Man kann das einstellen.
Prozentual vom Gesamt-RAM.
Also viel RAM wird geteilt.
15 GB wert.
Aber der Swap ist immer noch ziemlich niedrig.
1 MB Swap.
Also nur 1 MB wird für Swap genutzt.
Was bedeutet, es ist wirklich aus dem RAM.
Aber diese Intel NUCs sind ein Biest.
Sie laufen 5 bis 6 Virtual Machines.
Und sie sind rock-solid.
Und sie sind alle mit meiner NAS für Backups verbaut.
Wie Sie hier sehen können.
Also, weil wir über...
Soll ich mal kurz angucken?
Das ist cool, dass das Proxmox eingebaut hat.
Oh, okay.
Also, wir haben hier Backups, wie Sie hier sehen können.
Also, weil wir über meine NAS sprechen,
gehen wir in meine NAS,
die TrueNAS Scale ist.
Also, ich bin immer noch bei TrueNAS.
Ich habe TrueNAS genutzt,
seit es FreeNAS genutzt wurde.
Und dann war es TrueNAS und dann...
FreeNAS hatte ich auch mal.
Das war...
Also, wie gesagt, noch FreeNAS.
Also noch auf BSD-Basis.
Das war ganz okay.
Aber nachdem ich von ZFS weg bin,
das Schlimmste an FreeNAS
war die FreeNAS-Community.
Wenn du da irgendwas gesucht hast
und Glück hattest,
dass es einen Google-Treffer gab,
bist du im FreeNAS-Forum gelandet.
und Glück hattest, dass es einen Google-Treffer gab,
Leute, ich glaube, ich habe noch nie
ein Forum...
Okay, das Microcontroller-Forum ist vielleicht
ähnlich schlimm.
Das mal außen vor.
Das ist, glaube ich, das Schlimmste, was es gibt.
In der Richtung.
Ich habe noch nie einen Forum gesehen,
wo so viele alte Säcke
am Start waren,
die über kleinste Sachen
erst mal 30 Seiten
so circle-jerked haben,
weil irgendwie einer
doch tatsächlich
auf die Idee gekommen ist,
im Heimbereich
ZFS zu verwenden,
ohne mindestens
ECC-RAM
mit einem Gig
pro...
Nee, was für eine Empfehlung ist das?
Was empfehlen die da immer standardmäßig?
Ein
Gigabyte pro Terabyte
zusätzlich oder sowas?
Ja.
Dazu dann Leute, die hatten 2030T,
hatten aber bloß, keine Ahnung,
16 Gig
Memory und das war nicht ECC.
Boah, Alter,
sind die da immer ausgeflippt.
Und so unsinnig vor allem.
Als wäre das irgendwie ein Problem
im Heimbereich 16 Gig
16 Gig Kiste zu nehmen
oder als wäre das irgendein Problem
das nicht mit ECC
zu betreiben.
Das macht
das auf jeden Fall alles nicht schlechter
als normale
File Systems.
Ja, du kannst
vielleicht manche ZFS
Features nicht ganz
zu 100%
wie soll man sagen, ähm,
Vollständigkeit
benutzen und nicht drauf verlassen.
Aber das funktioniert
trotzdem
zuverlässiger und besser
als wenn du das dir selbst
zusammenschustest mit einem
MD-Rate oder einem normalen File System.
Also es macht über...
Und du brauchst auch nicht ein Gigabyte RAM
pro Terabyte im Heimbereich
wo du ab und zu mal drauf zugreifst
um deine Steuererklärung drauf abzulegen.
Ja,
das ist genau das Ding. Dieses
RAM, das ist so dumm, Alter.
Das ist so dumm. ECC
Du Quatsch! Du brauchst...
Wenn du da... Wenn irgendjemand
daheim seine alte Ryzen Kiste
nimmt mit 16 Gig, ja?
Da drei Platten
reinsteckt und FreeNAS
auf die SSD draufhaut,
ist das vollkommen okay für
eine Netzwerkstorage. Vollkommen okay.
Das Ding braucht keinen ECC-RAM
und das unterstützt ja nochmal ECC-RAM.
Natürlich ist es besser, wenn du eine
Kiste hast mit ECC-RAM.
Aber wenn nicht, macht es das auch nicht schlechter
als wenn du einfach ein X4 drauf
klatschen würdest und ein Samba und es freigibst.
Das ist nicht schlechter.
Es ist wenn schon nur besser.
Ja, dann muss das jemand ein RAM neu kaufen.
Also...
Ich weiß nicht, was mit Leuten...
Ja, das Microcontroller-Forum ist das
allerschlimmste. Das ist wirklich
so das
Meme-Forum für mich, wenn es um schlechte Foren
geht. Bitflips, Alter.
Beim nächsten Sonnensturm oder
sind dann deine ganzen Daten
korrupt wegen Bitflips?
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Für mich auch.
Ist das der Storynator?
Nee, das ist nicht der Storynator.
Der Storynator hat eine andere Farbe gehabt.
ZFS hat, was, 6 Cores?
Sie sind alle mit niedrigeren Kloppspeed,
aber das ist perfekt für den NAS, weil es
sehr wenig Kraft verwendet.
Alles was für den NAS betrachtet.
ZFS Cache oder generell
ZFS was RAM-Usage angeht
ist insofern schon nice,
weil ZFS buffert erstmal alles im RAM
und du hast super, also
ultra krasse Ride-Speeds
auf ZFS
bis der RAM voll ist
oder bis die Grenze erreicht ist,
worin er dann anfängt, dass es jetzt endlich weggeschrieben wird.
Du hast wirklich
das
hämmert nur so durch, durch Netzwerke.
Natürlich brauchst du auch ordentlich RAM.
Oder du überträgst halt nicht so viel.
Also ich hatte, ich bilde mir ein,
ich hatte auf der fetten Kiste hatte ich
ich glaube 48 GB RAM
und das war schon vor ein paar Jahren,
das war teuer.
Ich hatte 48 GB RAM
auf dieser 4AE Kiste
und da konntest du per 10 GB schon
sauschnell
mal ein Image oder so rüberschieben.
Das hat gemacht, flutscht,
dann war es drüben, war dann erstmal im RAM
und wurde dann weggeschrieben.
ZFS ist eine mega geile Sache.
Für den Heimbereich ist es
mir zu,
ich wollte gerade sagen zu Maintenance aufwendig,
das stimmt aber gar nicht, das ist es gar nicht mal so.
Zu komplex für den Heimbereich,
weil, wenn
mal da irgendwas kaputt geht,
da muss ich mich erstmal wieder
einen Tag mit ZFS beschäftigen,
bis ich das Ding an einem anderen Rechner
gescheit importiert bekommen hab.
Weil ich natürlich nach
zwei Jahren, seit dem Aufsatzzeitpunkt
alles wieder vergessen hab.
10 Drives in it.
But my NAS provides a lot of storage services,
is what I call it,
but it provides SMB, so Windows Shares,
NFS Shares,
and also iSCSI Targets,
because I need some iSCSI Drives for some of my machines.
And one additional thing that it's also doing
is running Minio on top of it,
that's the only app that I use,
and that gives me object storage,
so that I can do my backups,
and I can use object storage
within my network, instead of using
S3 or anything like that.
The nice thing about running it on here,
is then it's on top of ZFS,
and then I can do snapshots,
and it's not inside of my virtual machine.
Ich weiß, dass es theoretisch einfach nur
ein ZFS-Import ist,
aber ich weiß, dass es easy ist.
Aber ihr könnt doch darauf wetten,
wenn irgendwie was kaputt geht,
wenn da irgendwie eine Platte drin ist,
und es dann irgendeinen Import-Fehler gibt,
da musst du ewig rumsuchen
und gucken und machen.
Es ist nie so einfach,
wie es in der Theorie aussieht,
wenn wirklich was kaputt ist.
Also wenn ich eine Sache gelernt habe,
ist, dass Pläne, die man gemacht hat,
zu, ach wenn was kaputt geht,
dann machen wir einfach das und das,
dass das genau bis dann hält,
wenn wirklich was kaputt geht.
Es ist eigentlich besser,
man geht davon aus, es ist nie so einfach,
aber an sich ist ZFS nicht so schlimm,
was das angeht.
ZFS ist sehr komplex,
was du alles damit machen kannst.
Das Basic Handling ist nicht so wild.
Wie gesagt,
ich habe letztens auch auf der Arbeit
erst was gebaut mit ZFS.
Für Compression.
Also hauptsächlich
für Filesystem-Compression war das.
Transparente Filesystem-Komprimierung
mit LZ...
Wie heißt das?
LZ...
Wie heißt das Ding?
LZ4 oder sowas?
Das hat geflutscht.
Da habe ich unsere Polygon-Blockchain-Daten
draufgeschoben.
Die waren vorher 12 Terabyte
und nach dem Komprimieren
waren die nur noch 3,5 Gig.
Äh, 3,5T.
Nicht 3,5 Gig, Alter.
3,5T.
Also lässt sich sehr gut komprimieren.
Hätte ich gar nicht erwartet.
3,5T wären vielleicht doch
etwas übertrieben krasse
Kompression gewesen.
Auf Hardware-Rate habe ich auch keinen Bock.
Deswegen finde ich den Ansatz,
was Unrate macht, eigentlich ganz gut.
Du kannst die Platten nach wie vor
an jeder x-beliebigen Linux-Kiste anschließen
und runterziehen.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Der Satz war mir eindeutig
zu high IQ gerade.
Ich habe nichts verstanden.
Es ist outside vom Cluster, aber
inside vom Cluster, aber dann ist es
Backup outside vom Cluster.
Alles klar.
Jetzt hat er da alles drauf.
Okay, Miro.
Miro.
Er hat 12,
24, 36
Gig.
Ne, 48, oder?
Ne, 60. Kommt ja noch einer.
Eins, zwei, drei,
vier, fünf.
Fünf mal
zwölf.
60, ja.
Na gut. Fünf mal zwölf.
Dass ich das im Rechner rechnen muss.
Null.
Ich hatte
auf der alten Arbeit einen Kollegen,
der hatte auch ein ZFS, äh,
nicht ZFS, ZEFF
bei sich daheim laufen.
ZEFFFS
hat er bei sich laufen gehabt.
Der hatte dann auch irgendwann, keine Ahnung,
sieben Nodes oder so
und hat sich dann so ein komisches Ding
gekauft. Ich weiß nicht, wie das,
wie man sowas überhaupt nennt.
Das war irgendwie so ein USB.
Das war quasi ein eigenes
NAS per USB. Ne, kein NAS.
Das war, das war quasi
ein eigenes Gehäuse, wo du
Festplatten reinstecken konntest,
die du dann wiederum per USB an den Rechner
anschließen konntest. Wie heißt denn sowas?
Irgend so ein Storage Case halt.
Diskshelf. Ja, sowas in der Richtung.
Und der hatte dann irgendwann am Ende,
fragt mich nicht,
terabyteweise hatte der daheim
die, den Speicher.
Und der wusste am Ende schon gar nicht mehr,
was er drauf speichern soll. Da hat er angefangen,
sich mit irgendeinem Usenet-Account
Filme runterzuladen
und Serienarchive
anzunehmen und was auch immer. Der hatte so viel
Speicher, der wusste überhaupt nicht, was er damit machen soll, man.
Ich finde die Technik
cool, ja. Ich hätte bloß keinen
Bock, mich im zweiten Job daheim
dann noch drum zu kümmern.
Man könnte auch einfach
als einziges diesen
Raspberry Pi Zero
verwenden, weil für DNS
reicht der voll und ganz aus.
Ist nicht so, als braucht es viel Leistung.
Aber warum?
Das bedeutet, dass ich
eigentlich drei DNS-Server habe,
aber ich schicke nur die IPs
der primären und der
zweiten. Und die zweite ist
eine Laufbalance zwischen den beiden.
Ah!
Okay, jetzt
hab ich's verstanden. Sein primary
DNS geht direkt auf ein Pi-Hole
und der secondary DNS
geht auf ein low-balanced Pi-Hole,
dass wenn einer davon
abkackt, es immer noch
funktioniert.
Könnte man nicht einfach ein primary
eintragen und als secondary
den Raspberry Pi Zero an der Wand
und gut ist?
Das ist ja doch schon einmal mehr
Hochverfügbarkeit, als du jemals
daheim brauchst.
Also, ich finde Pi-Hole ganz okay.
Ich hatte mir mal letztens,
letztens ist schon zwei Jahre oder so her,
wie heißt das andere Ding,
AdGuard angeguckt.
Das fand ich auch nicht verkehrt.
Ich werde aber, ich verwende aber
beides nicht mehr, weil
DNS-Blocking zunehmend
nicht funktioniert.
Das heißt,
wenn ich mir
die DNS-Blocker
anschauen würde,
dann würde ich
die DNS-Blocker
nicht mehr
abkacken.
Und dementsprechend
ist der, wie soll ich sagen,
der Anwendungszweck
fast, ja, immer weniger
vorhanden.
Zumal es auch sehr schwierig ist,
iPhones zu überreden,
einen eigenen DNS anzusprechen.
Da musst du immer zig Sachen umstellen.
Es gibt auch das Problem, dass manche
Webseiten nicht richtig laden,
wenn DNS-Anfragen nicht richtig
geladen sind.
Für Netzwerksmanagement
benutze ich natürlich den
Unified Network Controller,
weil ich viele
ubiquitane Geräte habe.
Und ich wähle diesen, weil ich
die Hardware habe,
es ist ein einziger Stift aus Glas,
um all meine Netzwerke,
all meine Firmware und
sogar meine Kameras zu managen.
Und außerdem sind ihre
mobilen Apps schön und wie du
schon gesagt hast,
ich benutze Unified Protect
für meine Home-Sicherheit.
Es hält all meine Sicherheitsfotos
auf diesem Gerät.
Es gibt ungefähr 10 Kameras,
die du hier sehen kannst.
Das ist ein cooles Setup,
wenn man auf so rundum
Hausansicht steht
und man das recorden möchte.
Ich glaube, da ist es ganz nice
und wahrscheinlich auch zuverlässiger
als meine Bastellösung.
Ich habe ein paar Kameras im WLAN hängen,
die ich mir über ein Webinterface
per WebRTC angucken kann. Fertig.
Das wars.
Warum jetzt noch doppelt
und was auch immer.
Portainer to manage that.
One migration I did finish up this year
was moving all of my Docker
only hosts to Kubernetes.
So if we look in Portainer,
which I use to manage my Docker only hosts,
we can see that I have one stack
and that one stack is Watchtower
Okay, Unsinn, ich kann weg, brauchen wir nicht.
...there for testing.
And that's kind of how I use Docker right now.
I use Docker to spin it up,
to test it out, to see if I like it,
run it for a couple of days,
and if that's what it is,
I'll move it over to my Kubernetes cluster.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Anwendungsfall,
den ich nachvollziehen kann.
Zum Ausprobieren.
Aber das Ding ist,
warum braucht man dafür
einen extra Docker-VM-Server
oder sonst was.
Das mache ich bei mir einfach lokal in der VM.
Wenn ich was ausprobieren will.
Zur Not könntest du es auch in Proxmox starten.
Wobei Proxmox nicht
direkt Docker-Container macht.
Da müsstest du quasi Docker in Proxmox LXC
starten.
...my Kubernetes Cluster.
I have three Kubernetes Clusters
and I manage them all with Rancher.
I have my local cluster
which is K3S
and it's only running Rancher.
Then I have my cluster 01
which is kind of my untrusted cluster.
It's a little bit of both right now
because I'm in the middle of a migration.
But it runs all of my public workloads
along with a few internal workloads too.
But that's where cluster 02 comes in
and this is meant to run
all of my private
or my internal services
and nothing in it will be public facing.
And so with Rancher I manage
all three of these clusters.
You might be wondering, why do you need Rancher?
Technically I don't need Rancher.
I'm very familiar and very comfortable
with the CLI or using any kind of tools
like Lens or anything like that.
But I found having Rancher installed
in my cluster gives me
web management, gives me a lot of discoverability
and it gives me
a lot of flexibility.
I can even understand that.
It's a tool and it's good
because you got used to it.
I never got used to Rancher
so I didn't know
what I should use it for.
I now know most of the options
of CUBE CLI
by heart
especially the auto-complete
is pretty good.
And yes, it's called CUBE CLI
and not CUBE CUTTLE
as some people say.
It's an easy way
to debug something
when something goes wrong.
That being said,
I don't deploy my workloads
with Rancher.
It's called CUBE CTL.
It's definitely not CUBE CUTTLE.
I don't manage my workloads
with Rancher.
I do that with GitOps
which we'll talk about here in a little bit.
But I run a ton of workloads
in Kubernetes as you can see.
Was hat er alles?
39 deployments?
Was hat er alles laufen?
In seinem Kubernetes.
Das meiste davon
ist bestimmt auch Management-Kram.
Zählt er die CUBE Systems
Sachen und sowas mit?
Hier?
Also ist da sein Ingress mit dabei?
Irgendwelche Image-Updater?
Rancher
selbst und so?
Dann wird's das natürlich erklären.
Okay, so those are all pods that I put there.
A lot of stuff going on in here
that we'll talk about here in a little bit.
But I do use Kubernetes pretty heavily.
But if you want to dive into the nodes
that are running in this cluster,
I have one, two, three,
four, five nodes that are workers.
So these are running workloads.
And then I have one, two, three
that are running control plane in etcd.
So what does that mean?
Well, five of them are running all of the workloads
that I put on there.
And then three of them are running Kubernetes itself,
running the control plane to communicate
with the entire cluster
and running etcd, which is the internal database
for it to store all
of the Kubernetes information
and metadata about the cluster.
And you can see I have some labels on these nodes.
So I have a label for network.
And these three nodes here are running in the untrusted VLAN.
And then these last two nodes
Das ist so übertrieben!
are running.
One is in servers trusted.
That's the one that was on the diagram.
The other one is running in IoT.
I mentioned earlier it's running in the IoT VLAN.
Oh!
Oh, viel Spaß!
Dann muss er sich um Node Affinity kümmern
in seinen Deployments.
Dass die Dinge auch
schön auf dem richtigen
Worker landen.
Ich mein,
einmal gemacht kann man's
immer copy-pasten, aber du musst halt dran denken.
Weil normalerweise würde Kubernetes
das einfach schedulen
auf irgendeinem Node, was es für richtig hält.
Wenn er will, dass es hier
in diesem Node läuft, dann muss er
Node Affinity einstellen.
Das ist immer sehr hakelig.
Was ist eigentlich aus dem Typ geworden,
der immer Home Assistant in seinen Videos
gesagt hat?
Ich hab vergessen, wie der heißt.
Der mit der Klatze, der immer in seinen Videos gesagt hat
Home Assistant!
Kennt den jemand?
So einer mit Klatze.
Ich komm grad nicht auf den Namen.
Okay.
Die Dinger machen halt gar nix.
Okay, okay, weiter.
Welche Workloads kriegen wir
nicht gezeigt, oder?
Oh! Leute, jetzt kommt sowas wie
Argo CD oder sowas an den Start.
That means every piece of service
and infrastructure as far as load balancers
and possibly even nodes, you define
in code and you commit them
to a Git repo and you push
them up and then you let CI
take over and deploy those...
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Was, was haben wir denn hier?
Okay, jede Menge Kubernetes Manifests
und das Uptime Kuma Deployment.
Okay. Customize.
Da würde mich tatsächlich
interessieren, was er benutzt.
...sources to your cluster.
So then your Git repo
becomes the source of truth
and not the cluster itself
or the UI that you're looking at.
And I follow this practice pretty
exclusively. And so there isn't
a lot to show you other than some YAML.
But for example, you can see this is...
Also ich vermute mal, sie Cluster Nodes
baut er mit Ansible auf, weil
das initiale Einrichten der Nodes
und...
...my deployment for Uptime Kuma...
...GitHub Actions
eine Deploying, die aber nichts in Cluster ist.
Ich tippe mal auf Argo CD,
vielleicht auf Flux, kann auch sein.
...have a lot of properties set on here,
but at the end of the day,
when I commit and deploy this,
this is going to tell my cluster
what the desired state is,
and then the cluster will say, okay,
well, I'll make it that way.
So for example, if I wanted to give it a little more CPU,
I could change this value right here,
commit that, deploy it,
and then within a minute or so,
my cluster would see this come in,
and then it would redeploy this container
with the new request value.
And so what does that for me?
Well, it's Flux. I have Flux installed in my cluster.
Ah, Flux.
Nicht Argo CD. Okay.
...and it helps orchestrate all of this stuff within Kubernetes.
Worth mentioning too that I'm using Renovate,
or the...
Das ist cool. Das benutze ich auch.
Damit kann man checken, ob Images
und generell Ressourcen,
die man in seinen Kubernetes Manifests verwendet,
ob es für die Versionsupdates gibt.
Das kann nicht nur Images, das kann...
alle möglichen Dinger mittlerweile checken.
Das ist wirklich sehr nice, Renovate.
Renovate Bot.
So the Renovate Bot will look at my repo,
see if there are updates for some of the containers
that I'm using.
If there are, it'll open a pull request
or a merge request,
and then all I have to do is approve
or merge in that pull request,
and then that gets deployed.
So we can see that here if we look at the Uptime Kuma image.
You can see right now I'm using 123.11 Alpine,
but you can see there was a pull request
yesterday to update this
to .11.
Renovate ist nervig. Ja, das stimmt.
Die meisten Sachen sind halt
dann ewig offen und keiner kümmert sich drum.
Aber ich finde, es ist ein sehr nice Tool.
So previously it was .10.
I got a pull request from a bot
that I created that runs Renovate Bot.
It wanted to merge in .11.
I accepted that merge and then that
got deployed. So these two
work really well together to help keep
your cluster up to date and then keep it
functioning. And if you're curious about GitOps,
with Flux or Renovate Bot, I have
videos on both of those. Next is
reverse proxy and I'm still
using traffic. Now I have
Ich mag Traffic
überhaupt nicht.
Three instances
of traffic now running. Two inside
of one cluster and one inside
another cluster. So technically
this diagram isn't right. I actually
Nginx, Incra's best.
We have two of these. I have two of these
Metal LBIPs right here.
Ah, es muss Metal
LB sein. Ja klar.
Logisch. Kubernetes bringt nach
Standard Nginx mit und das ist lokal.
Da ist kein Cloud-Anbieter drunter,
der das umsetzen könnte.
Muss ja sowas in der Richtung sein.
Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an. Monitoring
und Logging.
Ich finde Uptime Kuma ist eine richtig
nice Sache.
Mir persönlich ist es etwas
zu minimalistisch.
Das ist eindeutig
fokussiert auf
Up-Down-Checks
von Webservices. Ich weiß, man kann
mittlerweile auch ein bisschen mehr damit machen.
Aber mir fehlt eine ordentliche
History und auch eine ordentliche
Auswertung. Ja, zum Beispiel
dass ich gucken kann, okay
Festplattenauslastung von
irgendeinem System, dass ich auch mal nachgucken
kann, okay, wie ist denn der Verlauf
davon so gewesen.
Den Check
Festplattenauslastung über 60
Prozent, äh über 90 Prozent,
den kriegt man im Zweifelsfall per
Push-Monitor in Uptime Kuma noch rein.
Wenn es nur das ist.
Ich hänge immer noch auf meiner
Zabbix-Installation lokal.
Obwohl ich Zabbix nicht mag.
Aber ich mag
ich mag die wenigsten Monitoring-Tools.
Es gibt, sie sind alle
irgendwie auf ihre Art Schrott.
Zabbix ist cool, aber Zabbix ist halt
die Grafen, wenn du das mal mit
Grafana vergleicht,
ein kompletter Rotz.
Aber glücklicherweise gibt es ein ganz cooles
Grafana-Plugin.
Aber dafür hast du dann wieder zwei Systeme, das ist halt
doof.
Prometheus ist
auch eine Option, wobei Prometheus
halt eher fürs Matrix-Collecten ist.
Weniger für so klassisches
Up-Down-Monitoring.
Für Sachen wie
Festplattenauslastung, klar, warum nicht, wenn du
den passenden Exporter installiert hast.
Aber Prometheus ist halt
mehr, ich baue mir mein Monitoring
selber, als wenn du sowas
Komplettes wie Zabbix verwendest.
Ja, du musst
bei Prometheus dir quasi dein Monitoring
aus Einzelteilen zusammenbauen.
Grafana fürs Frontend,
du brauchst irgendeinen Prometheus-Server,
da musst du dich dann um dein
Inventory kümmern, wie auch immer du das machst.
Dann musst du gucken, wie machst du das mit Alerts.
Welche Services
kannst du checken
und brauchst du welche
Exporter brauchst du dafür?
Prometheus
ist ziemlich das Selbstgebäue, wenn man
damit klassisches Monitoring
machen will.
Wofür Prometheus gut ist, ist,
wenn du Anwendungen, die selbst
Metriken exportieren, überwachen willst
oder aber, wenn es dir reicht, dass du
den Standard-Node-Exporter auf jede
Linux-Kiste haust, wobei dann eigentlich
viel zu viel, viel zu viel eigentlich
fast schon wieder drin ist.
Und ich persönlich finde ja, Alerting mit
Alert-Manager,
grausig.
Ich weiß, man kann auch mittlerweile dieses
Unified-Alerting in Grafana verwenden,
zumindest in der Theorie, weil das habe ich
praktisch noch nie benutzt.
Also sprich, wenn man Prometheus
verwendet für
mehr als Metriken
einsammeln von irgendwelchen Anwendungen,
die Metrik-Endpunkte haben,
dann musst du dir sehr
vieles, was du für Monitoring brauchst,
selber stricken.
Was du bei sowas Fertigem wie
Zabbix nicht brauchst.
Dafür hat Zabbix ein abartiges
Webinterface
und keiner checkt es wirklich.
Checkmk mag ich auch nicht.
Das wirkt so, als hatten die die letzten
15 Jahre keinen UI-Designer.
Hatten sie auch nicht.
Ist ja ein offenes Geheimnis,
dass sie das nicht hatten.
Jetzt mittlerweile haben sie einen
seit einem Jahr oder so.
Der kann dann aber auch nicht mehr viel machen.
Das ist der Alert-Manager.
Du meinst Unified Alerting
in Grafana.
Aber du hast den wichtigsten Part
geskippt, Chatge.
Ich hau alles von Prometheus ins Grafana rein.
Jaja, wenn es erstmal
in Prometheus ist. Du musst dir die Sachen erstmal
da reinbekommen.
Also das ist bei
Standard-Dingern wie Anwendungen,
die einen Metrik-Endpunkt anbieten,
kein Problem. Das ist, wenn
du einfach nur die Standardsachen
von irgendeinem Linux-System
abgreifen möchtest.
Auch kein Problem.
Dann nimmst du den Standard-Node-Exporter
und gut ist.
Wenn du Custom-Sachen machen willst,
dann wird es schon ein bisschen komplizierter.
Willst du zum Beispiel checken,
ob deine Webseite ab oder down ist,
dann brauchst du den Blackbox-Exporter.
Den musst du dann irgendwo laufen lassen,
konfigurieren, einstellen in deinem
Prometheus-Yaml, dass da richtig abgefragt wird.
Und wenn du gar
so recht spezialisierte
Custom-Checks machen möchtest,
wie zum Beispiel
ein Zertifikat-Gültigkeit
und solche Sachen und Warnungen dazu,
wird es nochmal ein bisschen komplizierter.
Also, für so klassisches
Monitoring ist es
viel Selbstgebau und
aus Einzelteilen zusammen
Geflicke, wenn man
Prometheus Grafana als
alleinige Monitoring-Lösung verwenden will.
Das stimmt. Ja, das geht.
Das stimmt. Ja, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Aber das
bringt dir ja nichts. Also ich meine,
dann hast du wieder das Problem.
Der Inhalt muss ja irgendwie in das File reinkommen.
Der erscheint ja dann
nicht auf magische Art und Weise in dem
File deine Zertifikats-Gültigkeit.
Ja, ja. Musst du. Musst du.
Aber bei Prometheus sage ich,
musst du die ganzen
Sachen entweder selbst bauen oder die aus
unterschiedlichen Teilen zusammenbauen.
Wenn du Zabbix installierst,
dann aktivierst du das, oh, wie heißt
das bei Zabbix?
Das Zertifikats-Monitoring,
wie heißt dieser Campbell,
dieser XML-Shit von Zabbix?
Ich habe es vergessen. Aktivierst du dein
Zertifikat-Monitoring, dann macht er das.
Dann ist gut.
Ja, das ist gleich wie bei Nagios.
Da hast du
über 20 Jahre zusammengebaute
Plugins. Kennt noch jemand
NRPE, wie hieß das Ding
bei Nagios?
NRPE-Exporter oder so?
Wie hießen das nochmal?
Bei Nagios war das immer, dass du,
wenn du Scripts
auf Server-Seite,
also auf Client-Seite ausführen
wolltest, da gab es irgendwie so
NRPE-Exporter oder so
was. Schon ewig her, dass ich was mit
Nagios gemacht habe. Das war auch
etwas weird.
Aber man ist dahinter gekommen.
Also ich sage gar nicht, dass du das nicht
alles mit Prometheus machen kannst.
Bei Prometheus ist es halt,
das, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe,
ziemlich viel, wenn man da wirklich um,
wenn man alles machen möchte mit
Prometheus-Metriken und, sagen wir mal so,
klassisches Monitoring inklusive Alerts.
Es ist halt viel selbst
zusammengebaut aus
unterschiedlichen
Teilen, die es vielleicht schon gibt
oder die man halt vielleicht auch selbst bauen muss.
Wenn man so etwas Komplettes nimmt, wie Zabbix,
ist das weniger der Fall.
Wenn du natürlich ganz spezielle
Anforderungen hast, wo es noch gar nichts
für gibt, dann da auch.
Okay, du kannst dich auch noch daran
erinnern, ja.
Aber es gibt irgendwie keine Monitoring-
Software, die mir gefällt so richtig.
Ich finde, Prometheus
Grafana ist richtig nice,
wenn man Metriken einsammeln will,
die schon zur Verfügung gestellt werden.
Wenn ich irgendeine Anwendung habe,
die hat einen Metrix-Endpoint, ich kann den einfach
abfragen, super, das ist das Beste.
Genau dafür ist es ja auch gemacht.
Oh, das merkt man auch.
Ich kriege bei Prometheus schon Zustände,
wenn ich einfach nur checken will, ob Webseiten
up oder down sind. Brauchst du diesen
hässlichen Blackbox-Exporter,
dann musst du dich darum kümmern, dass das alles
umgelabelt wird, weil es sonst irgendwie falsch heißt.
Ist voll für den Arsch.
Man kann das alles machen,
aber man spürt,
dass es nicht
die Kernaufgabe davon ist.
Ich hänge bei mir privat
immer noch auf Zabbix, ich mag Zabbix aber auch nicht.
Wisst ihr, ich mag Nagios.
Nicht so, dass ich es mir daheim installieren würde.
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Leben kein Nagios daheim installieren.
Aber ich mag
Nagios aus, also den alten Nagios.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das, weiß nicht,
wie der aktuelle Nagios ist.
Ich mag den alten Nagios.
Und ich mag den eigentlich nur aus dem Grund,
weil ich als Azubi
viel Nagios gemacht habe.
Und ich fand das damals voll geil.
Heute würde ich es wahrscheinlich
im Leben nicht mehr freiwillig machen,
aber
irgendwie habe ich so ein Herz für Nagios
von früher noch.
Wir gucken jetzt aber erstmal das Video fertig,
sonst wird das heute nichts mehr.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Eins interner und eins externer,
while, my internal upcoming
QMA monitors a lot of
things that aren´t even exposed publicly
The only way to do that is
in my
71 00Web, das hier alles were
mir gesagt wird,
was auch die Zeit
erklärt.
Bis alles ist der gleiche Boot.
Also online
strukturiert ist
Ihre Wachtheide
But it watches everything that I have publicly hosted to make sure that that's still up.
And as far as Loki, Grafana and Prometheus goes, sad to say, I ended up pulling these out of my cluster.
So when I was running my One-U servers, I had plenty of headroom, plenty of CPU, plenty of disk space to support these types of services.
But after I moved to my Intel NUCs, I realized that they were a little too busy running these services.
Now, don't worry, I know it's important to monitor.
Ja, okay, das kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Wenn der einfach alle Metriken von allen Nodes und allen VMs da reinpumpt, dann sind das ja 10.000 Sachen pro Sekunde.
And to log and to visualize your data, I'm going to be bringing those back when I move my One-U servers to a colo.
Be sure you're subscribed to see that video.
Dann ist das aber kein Homelab mehr.
But when I move those to a colo, I'm going to bring these services back.
And then leave those only for my public-facing stuff.
But I still might bring them back internally for my other things, but I need to find a lighter-weight way of doing that.
Sobald mein Homelab nicht mehr in meinem Home steht, dann ist es kein Homelab mehr.
Home Assistant. Beste.
Ich würde Home Assistant nicht...
...im Kubernetes-Cluster laufen lassen.
Weil man da nicht Home Assistant OS verwenden kann.
Und dadurch nicht auf die ganzen fertigen Add-ons zurückgreifen kann, die sehr praktisch sind.
...my devices into iOS, into HomeKit, but I decided to get rid of that and just use Home Assistant...
Ja, stimmt. Okay, Chat, Chat, ich gebe euch recht, korrekt.
Wenn er dann umzieht ins Rechenzentrum...
...dann ist es wieder ein Homelab.
Ja, aber das finde ich blöd.
Wie gesagt, umso mehr ich manuell machen muss, umso...
Ja, ja, sind das klar.
Wobei man sagen muss, du musst sie dann natürlich auch gescheit konfigurieren.
Das geht ja normalerweise über das Webinterface von Home Assistant und dann fällt eine Config raus, die der Container schluckt.
Du kannst die Add-ons theoretisch als...
...weil ich mir nicht mehr sicher bin, ob das so gescheit funktioniert.
Du kannst sie zwar laufen lassen als Container...
...dann funktioniert aber auch...
...oftmals wahrscheinlich die Home Assistant-Integration nicht richtig, weil die Auto-Discovery von Home Assistant, URL und solche Geschichten benutzen, weil sie eben Add-ons sind und als Add-ons gedacht sind.
Die Home Assistant verwendet, was machen die Add-ons so?
Also, ich mache meine Add-ons auf.
Ist es aktuell gar nicht.
Also, ich habe als Home Assistant Add-ons...
...ich habe den Fiat Champ laufen.
Das ist die allerwichtigste Software.
Die ruft von meinem...
...Elektroauto...
...Informationen ab und packt sie in Home Assistant rein.
Das ist ein Home Assistant Add-on.
Dann habe ich...
...die Webcam-Geschichte laufen für WebRTC.
Wenn ich meine Kameras per WebRTC angucken kann.
Dann habe ich MQTT laufen.
Mosquito MQTT.
Dann habe ich ZigBee to MQTT laufen.
Für meine ZigBee-Geräte.
Dann habe ich Z-Wave.
Das Z-Wave Add-on laufen.
Ja, okay. Und ein SSH-Add-on, dass ich per SSH draufkomme.
Aber gerade die Z-Wave Add-on und das ZigBee Add-on...
...und für die Webcams und den MQTT-Pro-Card...
...finde ich nice, dass es das Fertig-als-Add-on gibt.
Man kann das meiste davon auch ohne Probleme selbst laufen lassen.
In Docker-Containern, wenn man sich selbst drum kümmern will.
Aber wenn es Fertig-Add-ons gibt, warum das nicht?
Ja.
Meine bevorzugte Musikrichtung.
Auf Bare-Metal, genau.
Du kannst sehen, ich habe viele Geräte hier drin.
Ich habe viel Zeit verbracht, um sie hier reinzunehmen.
Und ich habe auch einige Automationen und andere Dinge.
Du magst also Krach, ja.
Mein Opa hätte nicht gesagt Krach, mein Opa hätte gesagt Geräusch.
Mein Opa hat jegliche Musik, die nicht klassische Musik war, immer Geräusch genannt.
Und das ist der Grund, warum ich Home Assistant habe.
Und du kannst sehen, dass hier ein Kates-Node läuft.
Aber der hat sein Besteck auch Schanzzeug genannt.
Okay, das muss ich jetzt mal über, das muss ich jetzt mal skippen.
HomeKit-Kamera-Integration nutze ich nicht.
And another thing in my home automation is this Broadlink-Control.
This is something that I built a long time ago, so I can control my Broadlink-Devices.
I can control them through a UI.
But I also created an API that I can control.
Habe ich einen für die Klimaanlage im Einsatz.
So I can remote control those lights back there during my Twitch-Stream.
As you can see, if I click on flash, wait a second, this should flash those lights back there.
And if I click on back to blue, it should stop and they should just go to blue.
So I wrote this a long time ago.
I should probably just use Home Assistant to do that now.
And then.
Warum?
Warum neu bauen?
Wenn es funktioniert.
Wenn es funktioniert, ist doch gut.
Ich benutze hier mein Overlay.
Auch seit Jahren.
Wisst ihr, dass das noch ein .NET-Framework für .8-Anwendungen ist?
Für die Overlays.
Das habe ich vor Jahren mal gebaut.
Hast du lange Haare?
Nee.
Ich habe einen Bart, aber nicht irgendwie so diesen super langen irgendwie.
Weiß nicht.
Heavy-Metal-Bart.
Wobei, das ist da eher lange Haare.
Ich hatte früher lange Haare, aber das ist auch schon wirklich sehr lange her.
Über 20 Jahre.
Wenn ich Code gegen Home Assistant schreibe, anstatt Custom-Code gegen meine Custom-Solution schreibe,
könnte ich jetzt mehr Mielage aus dem Schreiben gegen Home Assistant bekommen.
Aber das bedeutet auch, dass ich einige meiner Bots wiederholen muss.
Also hey, vielleicht nächstes Jahr.
Aber das ist gratis und open source.
Es ist auf GitHub, wenn du interessiert bist.
Danach ist Data Sync und ich denke, ich werde diese Kategorie entfernen, weil ich keine Daten-Synchronisierung mehr mache.
Ich denke, ich werde diese Kategorie entfernen, weil ich keine Daten-Synchronisierung mehr mache.
Danach ist Links-Page und ich benutze immer noch meine eigene Links-Page.
Okay, dafür braucht man selbstverständlich ein Kubernetes-Cluster, das verstehe ich.
Es ist kostenlos und open source.
Es ist auf GitHub, wenn du es nutzen willst.
Aber es ist ein sehr einfacher Weg, ein Link-Schleifer zu erstellen.
Ich benutze also einen Link-Schleifer für viele meiner Links, damit ich Kontrolle über die Links habe.
Ja, das geht auch selbstverständlich nur im Kubernetes-Cluster.
Nicht nur sehen sie gut, sondern ich kann auch Schritte machen.
So weit geht Home-Entertainment.
Power-Management.
Ja gut, das ist ja auch so ziemlich das Einzige, was es gibt.
Das Web-Interface sieht...
Ich wollte euch vorfahren.
Das Web-Interface sieht sehr modern aus.
Drei!
Drei USVs!
Da siehst du halt mal wieder, was bei den Amis abgeht, Alter.
120 Volt Keck-Weight.
Ja, da gibt es den Web-Interface.
Das wurde seit 1993 nicht mehr geupdatet.
Das sieht halt echt aus, man.
Das ist ein Web-Interface, der nur für Netzwerke verwendet wird.
Und du kannst Informationen darauf sehen.
Also benutze ich nicht nur NutServer, um das zu visualisieren,
sondern auch Content-Management-Systeme.
Ich benutze noch drei Content-Management-Systeme.
Ich benutze WordPress für einen meiner alten Blogs.
Ich benutze Ghostblog für mein Weihes Portfolio.
Und ich benutze Wiki.js für ein community-basiertes Wiki für meine Discord-Community.
Nun, ich würde gerne in die Lösungen gehen.
Statix-Eyegenerator.
Für CI und CD oder kontinuierliche Integration und kontinuierliche Ermittlung.
Ich benutze eigentlich zwei Lösungen für das.
Ich benutze GitHub-Aktions-Runners, die in meinem Netzwerk, in meinem Cluster, gehostet sind.
Und ich benutze auch GitLab-Runners, um verschiedene Teile des Codes zu bauen und zu kompilen und Dinge in meinem Cluster zu deployieren.
Warum auch?
Weil ich both GitHub und GitLab benutze.
Und so, die Runners selbst zu hosten, ermöglicht, dass ich nicht mein Code auf shared Runners runne.
Und dann gibt es alles andere in meinem Umfeld.
Ich runne Custom-Code für Bots auf Twitch.
Ich runne Twitter, Discord.
Ich runne Longhorn für Storage in meinem Kubernetes-Cluster.
Ich runne Netboot XYZ, was wirklich nicht in eine Kategorie passt.
Aber ich benutze das, um meine Geräte zu networkbooten, damit ich sie auf Operationssystemen installieren kann.
Und die Liste geht weiter und weiter.
Und wie ihr sehen könnt, bin ich ziemlich aufgeregt über Cellphone.
Auch BMW ja mit Cinema,
und gaming ihr seht irgendwie auch die Portion, der man sich bewegen mag.
.
mich daheim, um meine Infrastruktur
mehr als nötig
zu kümmern. Ich mach da auch echt
nur dran, wenn es sein muss.
Richtig, genau. Er macht
Homelabbing, um
einfach just for fun.
Ich muss halt sagen,
wenn ich was testen will, ich mach das
ja auch, wir basteln ja auch viel.
Ich versuche
nach Möglichkeiten
nicht, das an meiner
Heiminfrastruktur zu testen.
Also ich lass das so, wie es ist.
Und im Zweifelsfall
hol ich halt ein Raspberry Pi
aus dem Schrank und mach da was
drauf, probier das aus und
lass es vielleicht mal ein paar Tage laufen
zum angucken oder ich teste
das in der VM
und gut ist, also ich brauch
das Zeug gar nicht,
um irgendwas zu testen
oder auszuprobieren oder zu lernen.
Genau, da hab ich halt
keinen Bock drauf.
Hehehe.
Ja.
So Leute.
Es ist 22 Uhr.
Wisst ihr, was das bedeutet?
Boomer müde.
Es gibt WubWubSleep, das verwendet
bloß nie einer. Guck mal.
Ich find das eigentlich richtig nice, das Emo.
NightStream? Ne, ich geh jetzt pennen.
Ja, BadGear ist das
universelle Sleep-Emote.
Herr Schocke, danke schön für den
Sub. Jetzt noch schnell den
Kubernetes-Cluster deployen, bevor ich ins
BadGear.
Ja.
Wird Zeit.
Aber, wie gesagt,
auf allen vier Nodes natürlich.
Alles klar.
Wir hören uns.
Die Tage.
Bis denn.
See you.